the following is a conversation with sam
harris one of the most
influential and pioneering thinkers of
our time he's the host of the making
sense podcast
and the author of many seminal books on
human nature and the human mind
including the end of faith the moral
landscape lying
free will and waking up he also has a
meditation app
called waking up that i've been using to
guide my own meditation
quick mention of our sponsors national
instruments
valcampo athletic greens and linode
check them out in the description to
support this podcast
as a side note let me say that sam has
been an inspiration to me
as he has been for many many people
first from his writing
then his early debates maybe 13 14 years
ago
on the subject of faith his
conversations with
christopher hitchens and since 2013
his podcast i didn't always agree with
all of his ideas
but i was always drawn to the care and
depth of the way he explored those ideas
the calm and clarity amid the storm of
difficult
at times controversial discourse i
really can't express in words how much
it meant to me
that he sam harris someone who i've
listened to
for many hundreds of hours would write a
kind email to me saying
he enjoyed this podcast and more
that he thought i had a unique voice
that added something to this world
whether it's true or not it made me feel
special and truly grateful to be able to
do this thing
and motivated me to work my ass off to
live up to those words
meeting sam and getting to talk with him
was one of the most
memorable moments of my life this is
the lex friedman podcast and here is my
conversation
with sam harris i've been enjoying
meditating with the waking up app
recently
it makes me think about the origins of
cognition
and consciousness so let me ask where do
thoughts come from
well that's that's a very difficult
question to answer uh
subjectively they appear to come from
nowhere
right i mean it's just they they come
out of
some kind of mystery that is at our
backs
subjectively right so which is to say
that
if you pay attention the nature of your
mind in this moment you realize that you
don't know what you're going to think
next right now you're expecting to think
something that
seems like you authored it right you
know you're not unless you
you're schizophrenic or you have some
kind of thought disorder where you where
your thoughts seem fundamentally foreign
to you
they do have a a kind of signature of
selfhood
associated with them and
people readily identify with them they
feel like what you are i mean this is
the thing
this is the spell that gets broken with
meditation
our default state is to feel identical
to the stream of thought right which is
fairly paradoxical because how could you
as a mind as a self you know if there if
there were such a thing as a self
how could you be identical to the next
piece of language
or the next image that just
springs into into conscious view
but and you know meditation
is ultimately about examining that that
point of view closely enough so as to
unravel it and
feel the the freedom that's on the other
side of that identification but
the um subjectively thoughts
simply emerge right and you don't think
them before you think them right there's
this first moment where
you know just anyone listening to us or
watching us now could
perform this experiment for themselves i
mean just imagine
something or remember something and just
just pick a memory any memory
right you've got a storehouse of memory
just promote one
to consciousness
did you pick that memory i mean let's
say you remembered
breakfast yesterday or you remembered
what you said to your spouse
before leaving the house or you
remembered what you watched on netflix
last night or you remembered
something that happened to you when
you're four years old whatever it is
right it first it wasn't there
and then it appeared and
that is not a i'm sure we'll get to the
topic of free will
ultimately uh that's not evidence of
free will
right why are you so sure by the way
it's very interesting
after no no free will of my own yeah um
everything just appears right but what
else could it do
and so that's that's the subjective side
of it objectively
you know we have every reason to believe
that many of our thoughts all of our
thoughts are
[Music]
uh at bottom what some part of our brain
is doing
neurophysiologically i mean that these
are the products of some kind of neural
computation and neural um representation
when you're talking about memories is it
possible to pull the string
of thoughts to try to get to its root
to try to dig in past the the obvious
surface
subjective experience of like the
thoughts pop out of nowhere
is it possible to somehow get closer to
the roots of where they come out of
from the the firing of the cells or is
it a useless pursuit to dig that
to dig into that direction well you can
get
closer to many many subtle
contents in consciousness right so you
can notice things more and more clearly
and have a landscape of mind open up and
become more
differentiated and more interesting and
if you take psychedelics
you know it opens up you know why
depending on what you've taken and
the dose you know it opens in directions
and to an extent that
you know very few people imagine would
be possible but for having had those
experiences
but this idea of you getting closer
to something to the the datum of of your
mind or such as something of interest in
there
or something that's more real is um
is ultimately undermined because there's
no place from which you're getting
closer to it
there's no your part of that journey
right like we
we we tend to start out you know whether
it's
in meditation or or in any kind of
self-examination
or you know taking psychedelics we start
out
with this default point of view of uh
feeling like we're the kind of on the
the rider on the horse of consciousness
or we're the
we're the man in the boat going down the
stream of consciousness
right but we're so we're differentiated
from
what we know cognitively uh
introspectively but that feeling of
being differentiated that feeling of
being a self that can strategically pay
attention
to some contents of consciousness
is what it's like to be identified with
some
part of the stream of thought that's
going uninspected right like that
it's a false point of view and when you
see that and cut through that then this
sense of
this this notion of going deeper kind of
breaks apart because really
there is no depth ultimately everything
is right on the surface everything
there's no center to consciousness
there's just consciousness and its
contents and that those those contents
can change
vastly again if you drop acid you know
the the contents change
but there's in some sense that doesn't
represent
a position of depth versus the continuum
of depth versus surface
has broken apart so you're taking as a
starting point that there is a horse
called consciousness and you're riding
it and the actual riding is very shallow
this is
all surface so let me ask about that
horse
what's up with the horse what what is
consciousness
from where does it emerge how like
fundamental is it to the physics of
reality
how fundamental is it to what it means
to be human
and i'm just asking for a friend so that
we can
build it in our artificial intelligence
systems
yeah well it remains to be seen if we
can if
we will build it uh purposefully or just
by accident
this is a major ethical problem
potentially uh that i mean
my concern here is that we we may in
fact
build artificial intelligence that
passes the turing test
which we begin to treat not only as
super intelligent because it obviously
is and
and demonstrates that but we begin to
treat it as conscious
because it will seem conscious we will
have built it to seem conscious and
unless we understand exactly how
consciousness emerges
from physics we won't actually know
that these systems are conscious right
we'll just you know they may say you
know listen you can't turn me off
because
that's a murder right and we will be
convinced
by that uh dialogue because
we will we will you know just in the
extreme case who knows when
we'll get there but you know if we build
something like
perfectly humanoid robots that are more
intelligent than we are so we're
basically in you know a westworld-like
situation
there's no way we're going to withhold
an attribution of consciousness from
those
machines so they're just going to seem
they're going to advertise their
consciousness
in every glance and every utterance
but we won't know and we won't know in
some deeper sense that it make
then we can be skeptical of the
consciousness of other people i mean
someone could roll that back and say
well you don't you know i don't know
that you're conscious or you don't know
that i'm conscious we're just passing
the turing test for one another but
that kind of solipsism isn't justified
you know biologically or i mean we just
anything we
understand about the mind biologically
suggests that you and i
are part of the same you know role that
role the dice
um in terms of
how intelligent and conscious systems
emerged in in the wet wear of
of brains like ours right so it it's not
parsimonious for me to think that i
might be the only conscious person or
even the only conscious primate
you know is i i would argue it's not
parsimonious to withhold consciousness
from
other apes uh and even other mammals
ultimately
and you know once you get beyond the
mammals then my intuitions are
not really clear the question of how it
emerges is genuinely
uncertain and ultimately the question of
whether it emerges
is still uncertain you can you know it's
not
it's not fashionable to think this but
you can certainly argue that
that consciousness might be a
fundamental principle of matter
that doesn't emerge on the basis of
information processing
even though everything else that we
recognize about ourselves as minds
almost certainly does emerge
like an ability to process language that
clearly is a matter of information
processing because you you can disrupt
that process in in ways that
is um it's just so clear
and um the problem that the confound
with consciousness is that
yes we can seem to interrupt
consciousness you can give someone
general anesthesia and then you
wake them up and you ask them what was
that like and they say nothing i don't
remember anything
but it's hard to
differentiate a mere failure of memory
from a genuine interruption in
consciousness whereas it's not with you
know interrupting speech
you know we know when we've done it and
it's
it's just obvious that you know you
disrupt the right neural circuits and
you know you've disrupted speech so if
you have to bet all your money
on one camp or the other would you say
do you earn a side of
pan psychism where consciousness is
really fundamental to our
to all of reality or more on the other
side which is like
it's a nice little side effect a useful
like
hack for us humans to survive where
on that spectrum where do you land when
you think about consciousness
especially from an engineering
perspective i'm truly agnostic on this
point i mean i think i'm you know it's
kind of in coin toss
mode for me i i don't know
and pan psychism is not so
compelling to me again it just seems
unfalsifiable i wouldn't know how the
universe would be
different if pan psychism were true just
to remind people pan psychism is this
idea that
consciousness may be pushed all the way
down into the most fundamental
constituents of matter so there might be
something that's like to be an electron
or
or you know a cork but
then you wouldn't expect anything to be
different at
you know the macro scale or at least i
wouldn't expect anything to be different
so it may be unfalsifiable it just might
be that reality is not
something we're
as in touch with as we think we are and
that if at its base layer
to kind of break it into mind and matter
as we've done
ontologically is to misconstrue it right
i mean
there's there could be some kind of
neutral monism at the bottom and this
you know this
idea doesn't originate with me this is
this goes all the way back to
bertrand russell and and others you know
100 plus years ago
but i just feel like that the concepts
we're using
to divide consciousness and
and matter it may in fact be part of our
problem
right where the rubber hits the road
psychologically here
are things like well what is death right
like
do we any expectation that we survive
death or any part of us survives death
that really it seems to be the the um
many people's concern here well i tend
to believe just as a small little
tangent
like i'm with ernest becker on this that
there's some
it's interesting to think about death
and consciousness which one
is the chicken which one is the egg
because it feels like death could be the
very thing
like our knowledge of mortality could be
the very thing that creates the
consciousness
yeah well then you're using
consciousness differently than than i
am so so for me consciousness is just
the fact
that the lights are on at all that
there's an experiential
quality to anything so so much of the
processing
that's happening in our brains right now
seems certainly seems to be happening in
the in the dark right like
it's not associated with this
qualitative
sense that there's something that's like
to be that part of
the mind doing that mental thing
but for other parts the lights are on
and and we can talk about
and whether we talk about it or not we
can feel directly
that there's something that is like to
be us
there's something something seems to be
happening right and
this seeming in our case is broken into
vision and hearing and and
proprioception and and
taste and smell and and thought and
emotion and
there's there are the contents of
consciousness
uh that we
are familiar with and that we can we can
have direct access to in any present
moment that when we're
quote conscious and
even if we're confused about them even
if you know we're asleep and dreaming
and we're really inward it's not a lucid
dream we're just totally confused about
our
circumstance what you can't say
is that we're confused about
consciousness like you can't say that
consciousness itself might be an
illusion
because on this account
it just means that things seem anyway at
all
i mean even like if this you know it
seems to me that i'm seeing a cup
on the table now i could be wrong about
that it could be a hologram i could be
asleep and dreaming i could be
hallucinating
but the seaming part isn't really up for
grabs in terms of
being an illusion it's it's not
uh something seems to be happening and
that seeming
is the is the context in which every
other thing
we can notice about ourselves can be
noticed and then
it's it's also the context in which
certain illusions can be
cut through because we're not we can be
wrong about what it's like to be us and
we can
uh i'm not saying we're incorrigible
with respect to
our claims about the nature of our
experience but
for instance this you know many people
feel like they have a self and they feel
like it has free will
and you know i'm quite sure at this
point that they're wrong about that and
that you can
you can cut through those experiences
and then things seem a different way
right so it's not that
it's not that things don't there aren't
discoveries to be made there and
assumptions to be overturned but um
this kind of consciousness is something
that i would think
it doesn't just come online when we get
language
it doesn't just come online when we form
a concept of death or
the the finiteness of life it doesn't it
doesn't require a sense of self
right so it doesn't it it's it's prior
to a differentiating self and other
uh and i wouldn't even think it's
necessarily
uh limited to people i mean i do think
probably
any uh mammal has this
but certainly if you're going to if
you're going to presuppose
that something about our brains is
producing this
right and that's a very safe
assumption even though it we can't
even you can argue the jury is still out
to some degree
then it's very hard to draw a principled
line between us and
chimps you know or chimps and and you
know rats
even in the end given the underlying
neural
uh similarities so um and i i don't know
you know phylogenetically i don't know
how far
back to push that you know it's there
people you think
single cells might be conscious or that
you know flies are certainly conscious
they've got
something like uh a hundred thousand
neurons in their brains and it says
it's just that's a there's a lot going
on even in a fly
right uh but i i don't have intuitions
about that but it's not
in your sense an illusion you can cut
through i mean to push back
the alternative version could be it is
an illusion constructed by
just by humans i'm not sure i believe
this but it
in part of me hopes this is true because
it makes it easier to engineer
is that humans are able to contemplate
their mortality
and that contemplation in itself creates
consciousness
that like the the rich lights on
experience so the lights don't actually
even turn on
in the way that you're describing until
after birth
in that construction so it's do you
think it's possible that that is the
case that it is a
sort of construct of the way we deal
almost like a social tool to deal with
the reality of the world
the social interaction with other humans
or is yeah because you're saying the
complete opposite which is it's like
fundamental to to
signal cell organisms and trees and
and so on right well yes i i don't i
don't know how far down to push it i
don't have intuitions that
single cells are likely to be conscious
but
but they might be and i just again i
could be unfalsifiable
um but as far as babies not being
conscious or
like you're not you don't become
conscious until you can recognize
yourself in a mirror or
you have a conversation or treat other
people first of all babies treat other
people as
others far earlier than
we have uh traditionally given them
credit for and they certainly do it
before they they have
language right so it's it's like it's
got to perceive language
to some degree and you can interrogate
this for yourself
because you can put yourself in various
states that are
rather obviously not linguistic you know
meditation allows you to do this you can
certainly do it with psychedelics where
it's just
your capacity for language has been
obliterated
and yet you're all too conscious in fact
uh yeah
you i think you could make a stronger
argument for
things running the other way that
there's something about
language and and conceptual thought that
is
eliminative of conscious experience that
that we're we are potentially much more
conscious
of data sense data and everything else
than we tend to be
and we have trimmed it down based on
how how we have acquired concepts and so
like
when i walk into a room like this i know
i'm walking into a room
i have certain expectations of what is
in a room you know
i would be very surprised to see you
know wild animals in here or a waterfall
or you know
there are things i'm not expecting but
i can know i'm not expecting them or i'm
expecting their absence because
of my capacity to be surprised once i
walk into a room and i see a you know
a live gorilla or whatever so
there's there's structure there that we
have put in place based on all of our
conceptual learning and language and
language learning and
it causes us not to one of the things
that happens when you take psychedelics
and you just look as though for the
first time
at anything it becomes
incredibly overloaded with uh it can
become overloaded with meaning
and and um uh
just the the torrents of sense data that
are coming in
in even the most ordinary circumstances
can become overwhelming for people and
it that tends to just
obliterate one's capacity to capture any
of it
linguistically and as you're coming down
right have you done psychedelics have
you ever done
acid or not acid mushroom
and that's it and also edibles but
that's
that there's some psychedelic properties
to them but right but yeah
mushrooms uh several times and always
had an incredible experience
it exactly the kind of experience you're
referring to which is
if it's true that language constrains
our experience it felt like i was
removing some of the constraints
right because even just the most basic
things were beautiful in the way that
i wasn't able to appreciate previously
like trees and nature and so on
yeah and the the experience of coming
down
is an exp is an experience of
encountering the futility of of
capturing
what you just saw a moment ago in words
right like especially if you have if any
part of your
your self concept and your your ego
program is to be able to capture things
in words and if you're a writer or a
poet or
or a scientist or someone who wants to
just
encapsulate the profundity of what just
happened
the the the
total fatuousness of that enterprise
when you really have got when you have
taken a you know a whopping dose of
psychedelics and you begin to
even gesture at cat describing it to
yourself you know so that you could
describe it to others
uh it's just it's like trying to you
know
thread a needle using your elbows i mean
it's like you're you're trying something
they
can't it's like the beer gesture proves
its impossibility uh and it's um
so yeah so that i mean that for me that
that suggests just
empirically on the first person side
that it's possible to put yourself in
a condition where it's clearly not about
language uh structuring your
experience and you're having much more
experience than you
you tend to so the primacy of language
is primary for
some things but
it's certainly primary for certain kinds
of concepts and certain kinds of
semantic understandings of of the world
but
it's uh it's clearly more to mind than
you know the conversation we're having
with ourselves or that we can have with
others can we go to that world of
psychedelics for
for a bit sure where do you think um
so joe rogan apparently and many others
uh meet
apparently elves when they on dmt
a lot of people report this kind of
creatures that they see
and again it's probably the failure of
language to describe that experience but
dmt is an interesting one
there's uh as as you're aware there's a
bunch of studies going on in psychedelic
psychedelics currently mdma um
uh south side and uh
john hopkins and a bunch of other places
but dmt they all speak of as like
some extra super level
of a psychedelic yeah do you have a
sense of where it is our mind goes
on um on psychedelics but in
in dmt especially well unfortunately i
haven't taken
dmt so unfortunately or fortunately
unfortunately
unfortunately uh although it's i presume
it's in my body as it is in
uh everyone's brain and in many many
plants
apparently but i've wanted to take it i
haven't been i had an opportunity that
was presented itself that where it was
obviously
the right thing for me to be doing uh
but
you know for those who don't know dmt is
is often touted as the most intense
psychedelic and also the shortest acting
i mean you smoke it and it's
it's basically a 10 minute experience or
a
or a three minute experience within like
a 10 minute window
uh that you when you're really down
after
10 minutes or so um
and terence mckenna was a big proponent
of dmt that was
that was his you know the center of the
bullseye for him psychedelically
apparently
um and it does it is characterized it
seems for many people
by this phenomenon which is which is
unlike virtually any other psychedelic
experience
which is your your it's not just your
perception
being broadened or changed it's you
according to terence mckenna feeling
fairly
unchanged but catapulted into a
a different circumstance you may have
been shot elsewhere
and find yourself in relationship to
other
entities of some kind right so so the
place is populated with
with things that seem not to be your
mind
so it does feel like travel to another
place because you're unchanged yourself
of course again i just have this on the
authority of the people who have
described their experience
but it sounds like it's a pr it's pretty
common it sounds like it's pretty common
for people not to have the full
experience because it's
apparently pretty unpleasant to smoke so
it's like getting enough on board in
order to get shot
out of the the cannon uh and land
among the uh what mckenna called
self-transforming machine elves
that appeared to him like jeweled you
know faberge egg like ba
self dribbling basketballs that were
handing him uh
completely uninterpretable reams of
profound knowledge
it's a it's an experience i haven't had
so i just have to
accept that people have had it
i would just point out that our minds
are clearly capable
of producing apparent others
on demand that are totally compelling
to us right there's no there's no limit
to our ability to do that as anyone
who's ever remembered a dream
can attest i mean we every night we go
to sleep some of us don't remember
dreams very often but
um some dream vividly every night
and just think of how insane that
experience is i mean
you you've forgotten where you were
right that's
the strangest part i mean this is
psychosis right you're you have
you have lost your mind you have lost
your connection
to your episodic memory
uh or even your expectations
that reality won't undergo wholesale
changes a moment
after you have closed your eyes right
like you
you're in bed you're you know watching
something on netflix you're waiting to
fall asleep
and then the next thing that happens to
you is impossible
and you're not surprised right you're
talking to dead people you're hanging
out with famous people you're
you're someplace you couldn't physically
be you can fly
and even that's not surprising right so
it's
you've lost your mind but relevantly for
this
or found it you found some i mean lucid
dreaming is very interesting because
then
then you can have the best of both
circumstances and it's
uh that then it can be kind of
systematically explored
but what i mean by found just to start
to interrupt is like
if we take uh this this brilliant idea
that language constrains us
grounds us language and other things of
the waking world ground us
maybe it is that you've found the full
the full capacity of your cognition when
you dream or when you do psychedelics
you're stepping outside the the little
human cage the cage or the human
condition
to get open the door and step out and
look around and then go back in
well you've you've definitely stepped
out of something and into something else
but you've also lost something
right you've lost certain capacities
well just
yeah in this case you literally didn't
you don't you don't
have enough presence of mind in the
dream in the dreamy city or even in
the psychedelic state if you take enough
uh
did you have there's no psychological
there's very little
psychological continuity with your life
such that you're not surprised to be
in the presence of someone who should be
you should know is dead or you should
know you're not likely to have met
by normal channels right you're you know
you're now talking to some celebrity
and it turns out you're best friends
right and you're not even
you have no memory of how you got there
you know like how did you get into the
room you're like how did
did you drive to this restaurant you
know you have no memory and none of
that's surprising to you so you're
you're kind of brain damaged in a way
you're not reality testing
in the normal way the fascinating
possibility is that
there's probably thousands of people
who've taken psychedelics of various
forms and
have met sam harris on that journey
well i would put it more likely in in
dreams not you know because
in psychedelic with psychedelics you
don't tend to hallucinate
in a dreamlike way i mean so dmt is
giving you a
an experience of others but it's it
seems to be
non-non-standard it's not like it's not
just like
dream hallucinations but but
to the point of coming back to dmt
the people want to suggest and
terence mckenna certainly did suggest
that because
these others are so obviously other
and they're so vivid well then they
could not possibly be the
the creation of my own mind but every
night in dreams
you create a a compelling or what is to
you
at the time a totally compelling
simulacrum of
another person right and uh that's
uh that just proves the mind that's
capable of doing it now it's it's uh
the the phenomenon of lucid dreaming
shows that the mind isn't capable of
doing everything you think it might be
capable of even in that
space so one of the things that
people have discovered in lucid dreams
and i i haven't done
a lot of lucid dreaming so i've i can't
confirm all of this so i can
confirm some of it um
apparently in every house in in every
room in the the mansion of dreams
all light switches are dimmer switches
like if you go into a dark room
and flip on the light it gradually comes
up it doesn't it doesn't come up
instantly on demand uh because you know
apparently this is covering for the
brain's inability to
produce from a you know a standing start
visually rich imagery on demand so
there's i haven't confirmed that but
that was
people have done research on lucid
dreaming
claim that it's all dimmer switches uh
but one thing i have noticed and
you know people can check this out is
that in a dream
if you look at text you know a page of
text
you know or a sign you know or a
television that has text on it
and then you turn away and you look back
at that text the text
will have changed right there's no the
total is it's just a
chronic instability graphical
instability
of text uh in the dream state and i
don't know if that you know maybe that's
someone can confirm that that's not true
for them but that's whenever i've
checked that out that has been true for
me it keeps generating it
like uh real time yeah from a video game
perspective
yeah it's render it's rendering it's
re-rendering it
for some reason what's interesting i
actually i don't know how i found myself
in this sets of uh that part of the
internet
but there's quite a lot of discussion
about what it's like to do
math on lsd because apparently
one of the deepest thinking processes
needed is those of mathematicians or
theoretical computer scientists
basically doing anything that involves
math is proofs
and you have to think creatively but
also deeply and you have to think for
many hours at a time and so they're
always looking for ways to
like is there is there any sparks of
creativity that could be injected and
apparently out of all the psychedelics
the the worst
is lsd because it completely destroys
your ability to do
math well and i wonder whether that has
to do with
your ability to visualize geometric
things
in a stable way in your mind and hold
them there and stitch things together
which is often what's required for
proofs but
again it's difficult to kind of research
these kinds of concepts but it does make
me wonder
where what are the spaces
how's the space of things you're able to
think about and explore
morphed by different by different
psychedelics
or dream states and so on and how's that
different how much does it overlap with
reality
and what is fundament what is reality is
there a waking state reality
or is it just a tiny subset of reality
and we get to take a step in
other versions of it we tend to think
very much
in a space-time four-dimensional there's
a three-dimensional world there's time
and that's what we think about reality
and we think of traveling
as walking from point a to point b in
the three-dimensional world
but that's a very kind of human
surviving
trying not to get eaten by a lion
conception of reality
what if traveling is something like we
do with psychedelics and meet the elves
what if it's something what if thinking
or the space of ideas as we kind of grow
and think through ideas that's traveling
or what if memories is traveling i don't
know if you have a
if you have a favorite view of reality
or if you're you had by the way
i should say a excellent conversation
when uh donald hoffman
yeah yeah he's interesting is there any
inkling
of his sense in your mind that reality
is uh
very far from actual like objective
reality is very
far from the kind of reality we imagine
we perceive and we
play with in our human minds well
the first thing to grant is that
there we are never in direct contact
with reality whatever it is unless that
reality is consciousness right so
we we're only ever experiencing
consciousness and its contents
and then the question is how does that
circumstance relate to quote reality at
large
and donald hoffman is somebody who's
happy to speculate well maybe there
isn't a reality at large maybe it's all
just
consciousness on some level and that
that's interesting
that runs into to my eye
various philosophical problems
that um or at least you have to do a lot
you have to add to that
uh picture i mean that you know a
picture of idealism for i mean that's
usually all the all the whole family of
views that would just
say that the universe is just mind or
just consciousness at bottom you know
we'll go by the name of idealism in
western philosophy
you have to add to that idealistic
picture all kinds of epic cycles and
kind of weird coincidences and to get
the to get the predictability of our
experience and the success of
of materialist science to make sense in
that context right so the fact that we
can
what does it mean to say that there's
only consciousness
at bottom right nothing outside of
consciousness because no one's ever
experienced
anything outside of consciousness as no
scientist has ever done an experiment
where they were contemplating data
no matter how far removed from our sense
bases you know whether it's they're
looking at the
hubble deep field or they're they're
smashing atoms or whatever that whatever
tools they're using
they're still just experiencing
consciousness and its
various deliverances and
layering their concepts on top of that
so
that's always true and yet that somehow
doesn't seem to capture
the um the character of our
continually discovering that our
materialist assumptions
are are confirmable right so you take
take the fact that we
we unleash this fantastic amount of
energy from within
an atom right you know we first we have
the theoretical
suggestion that it's possible right we
need to come back to einstein there's a
lot of energy
in that matter right and what if we
could release it
right and then we perform an experiment
at in this case
you know the trinity test site in new
mexico
where the people who are most adequate
to this conversation people like
robert oppenheimer uh
are standing around not all together
certain it's going to work
right they're performing an experiment
they're wondering what's going to happen
they're wondering if their calculations
around the yield are off by orders of
magnitude some of them are still
wondering whether the entire atmosphere
of earth is going to
kind of combust right that the
the the the nuclear chain reaction is
not going to stop
and lo and behold
there was that energy to be released
from within the nucleus of an atom and
that could so it's it's just
what what the picture one forms from
those kinds of experiments and just the
knowledge it's just our understanding of
evolution just the fact that
the the earth is billions of years old
and life is hundreds of millions of
years old and we weren't here
to think about any of those things um
and all of those processes were
happening therefore in the dark
and they are the processes that allowed
us to to emerge
you know from prior life forms in the
first place
to say that it's all a mass that nothing
exists
outside of consciousness conscious minds
of the sort that we
experience it just seems um
it seems like a bizarrely
anthropocentric
claim uh
you know analogous to you know the moon
isn't there if you're not if no one's
looking at it right
the moon as a moon isn't there if no
one's looking at it i'll grant that
because
that's already a kind of fabrication
born of concepts but the idea that
there's nothing there
that there's no nothing that corresponds
to what we experience as the moon
unless someone's looking at it that just
seems
just a way too parochial way to set out
on this
journey of discovery there is something
there there's a computer waiting to
render the moon when you look at it
the capacity for the moon to exist is
there so
if if we're indeed living in a
simulation
which i find a compelling thought
experiment uh is it's possible that
there is a kind of
rendering mechanism but not in a silly
way that we think about in video games
but in some kind of more fundamental
physics way
and we have to account for the fact that
it renders
experiences that no one has had yet
that no one has any expectation of
having
it can violate the expectations of
everyone lawfully right and then
some lawful understanding of how why
that's so
it's like um i'm just to bring it back
to mathematics something like certain
numbers are prime
whether we have discovered them or not
right like there's there's there's the
highest prime number
that anyone can name now and then
there's the next prime number that no
one can name
and it's there right so it's like it's
it's to say that
our minds are putting it there that what
we know as mind
in ourselves is in some way in some
sense putting it there
that like that that the base layer of
reality is consciousness
right you know that we're we're
identical to the thing that is rendering
this this reality there's some
you know hubris is the wrong word but
it's like there's some it's like
it's okay if reality is bigger than what
we experience
you know and and it has structure that
we can't anticipate and that isn't just
um i mean
again there's a co there's there's
certainly a collaboration between our
minds
and whatever is out there to produce
what we call
you know the stuff you know of life but
um it's not the idea that
it's uh i don't know i mean
there are there are a few stops on the
train of idealism
and kind of new age thinking and and
eastern philosophy that i don't
philosophically i don't see a need to
take i mean the place
experientially and scientifically i feel
like it's it's
it you can get everything you want
acknowledging that consciousness has a
as a character that can be explored from
its own side so that you're bringing
kind of the first person
experience back into the into the
conversation about you know what is a
human mind and you know what is true uh
and you can explore it with with
different degrees of rigor
and there are things to be discovered
there whether you're using a technique
like meditation or
psychedelics and that these experiences
have to be put in conversation
with what we understand about ourselves
from a third person side
neuroscientifically or in any other way
but to me the question is
what if reality the sense i have from
this kind of
you put you play shooters no there's a
physics engine that generate that's
probably
just first person shooter games yes yes
sorry uh not often but yes i mean
there's a physics engine that generates
consistent reality
right my sense is the same could be true
for a universe
in the following sense that our
conception of reality as we understand
it and now in the 21st century
is a tiny subset of the full reality
it's not that the reality
that we conceive of that's there the
moon being there is uh
not there somehow it's that it's a tiny
fraction of what's
actually out there and so the uh the
physics engine
of the universe is just maintaining the
useful
physics the useful reality quote-unquote
uh for us to have a consistent
experience as human beings
but maybe we descendants of apes are
really only understand like 0.0001
of actual physics of reality like this
we can even just start with the
consciousness thing
but maybe our minds are just we're just
too
dumb by design yeah i i i
that truly resonates with me and i'm
surprised it doesn't resonate more with
most
scientists that i talked to but when you
just look at
you look at how close we are to
chimps right and chimps don't know
anything right clearly they have no idea
what's going on right
and then you get us but then you it's
only a subset of human beings
that really understand much of what
we're talking about on any you know
in any area of specialization and if
they all died in their sleep
tonight right you'd be left with people
who might take a thousand years
to rebuild the internet you know or if
ever
i mean literally it's like like you know
and you know i i would i would
extend this to myself i mean there there
are areas of scientific specialization
where i have either no
discernible competence i mean i've spent
no time on it i have not
acquired the tools it would just be an
article of faith for me to think that i
could acquire the tools to actually make
a breakthrough in those areas
um and i mean you know your own area is
one i mean
like you know i i've never spent any
significant amount of time trying to be
a
a programmer but
it's pretty obvious i'm not alan turin
right it's like like if if that were if
that were my capacity
i would have discovered that in in
myself i would i would have found
programming irresistible
my few fault my first fall starts in
in learning i think it was c um
it was just you know i bounced off like
this was not fun i hate
trying to figure out what what you know
the syntax error that's causing this
thing not to compile
was just a [ __ ] awful experience i
hated it right i hated every minute a
minute of it
so it was not um
so if it was just people like me left
like when do we get the internet again
right and we lose
we lose you know we lose the internet
when do we get it again right when do we
get a
anything like a proper science of
information
right you need a claude shannon or an
alan turing
just to plant a flag in the ground right
here and say all right can everyone see
this
even you don't quite know what i'm up to
you all have to come
over here to to make some progress
and you know there are you know hundreds
of topics where that's the case
so we're bare we barely have a purchase
on making anything like discernible
intellectual progress in any generation
and yeah i'm
just a max tegmark makes this point he's
one of the few
people who does in physics
if you if you just to take the
the truth of evolution seriously right
and and
realize that there's nothing about us
that has evolved
to understand reality perfectly i mean
we just we're just not that
kind of ape right there's been no
evolutionary pressure along those lines
so what we are making do
with tools that were designed for
fights with sticks and rocks right
and it's amazing we can do as much as we
can i mean we just you know that you and
i are just sitting here on
on the back of having received an mrna
vaccine
you know that uh certainly changed our
life given what the last year was like
like and it's going to change the world
if rumors of coming miracles are
are borne out i mean if it's now um
seems likely we have a a vaccine coming
for malaria right which has been killing
millions of people a year for as long as
we've been alive
i think it's down to like 800 000 people
a year now because
we've spread so many bed nets around but
it was like two and a half million
people
every year it's amazing what we can do
but yeah i have if in fact the you know
the answer the book of nature
the back of the book of nature is you
understand
0.1 percent of what there is to
understand and half of what you think
you understand is wrong that would not
surprise me
at all it is funny to look at our
evolutionary history
even back to chimps i'm pretty sure even
chimps thought they end
under stood the world well so at every
point
in that timeline of evolutionary
development throughout human history
there's a sense like there's no more you
hear this message over and over
there's no more things to be invented
but a hundred years ago there were
there's a famous story i forget which
physicist
told it but there was there were
physicists telling
their their undergraduate students not
to go into
to get graduate degrees in physics
because basically all the problems had
been solved and this is like around
you know 1915 or so turns out you were
right i'm going to ask you about free
will oh
okay uh you've recently released an
episode of your podcast making sense
for those with a shorter attention span
uh basically summarizing your position
on free will
i think it was under an hour and a half
yeah yeah
that is as brief and clear
uh so allow me to summarize the summary
tlgr
and maybe you tell me where i'm wrong
so free will is an illusion and
even the experience of free will is an
illusion like we don't even
experience it what
am i am i good in my summary yeah
this is a this is a line that's a little
hard to
scan for people i i say that it's not
merely that free will
is an illusion the illusion of free will
is an illusion right like there is no
illusion of free will
and that is a unlike many other
illusions
uh that's a
a more fundamental claim it's like
it's not that it's wrong it's it's not
even wrong i mean that's i guess
that was uh i think wolfgang paulie who
derided one of his uh
colleagues or enemies with that uh
um aspersion about his theory
in quantum mechanics um
it's so there are things that you there
there are genuine illusions there are
things that
you do experience and then you can
kind of punch through that experience or
you can't you can't actually experience
you can't you can't experience them any
other way it's just um
it's we just know it's not a vertical
experience just take like a visual
illusion there are visual illusions that
you know
a lot of these come to me on twitter
these days there's these amazing
visual illusions where like you know
that every figure
in this gif seems to be moving but
nothing in fact is moving you can just
like put a ruler on your screen and
nothing's moving
um some of those illusions you can't see
any other way i mean they're just
they're
hacking aspects of the visual system
that are just
eminently hackable and you you know you
you have to use a ruler
to to convince yourself that the thing
isn't actually moving
now there are other visual illusions
where you're taken in by it at first
but if you pay more attention you can
actually see that it's not there right
or it's not how it first seemed like the
uh like the necker cube is a good
example of that like the necker cube is
just that
schematic of a cube of a transparent
cube which pops out one way or the other
the one one face can pop out and the
other face can pop out
but you can actually just see it as flat
with no pop out
which is a more vertical way of looking
at it
so there are subject there are kind of
inward
correlates to this and i would say that
the um
[Music]
the sense of self a sense of self and
free will are closely related i often
describe them as
as two sides of the same coin but
they're not quite the same
in the their their spuriousness i mean
so the sense of self is something that
people i think do experience right it's
not a very clear experience
but it's not i wouldn't call the
illusion of self and illusion
but the illusion of free will is an
illusion in that
as you pay more attention to your
experience
you begin to see that it's totally
compatible
with an absence of free will you don't i
mean coming back to the place we started
you don't know what you're going to
think next you don't know what you're
going to intend
next you don't know what's going to just
occur to you
that you must do next you don't know you
don't know how much you're going to feel
the behavioral imperative to act on that
thought
if you suddenly feel oh i don't need to
do that that's i can do that tomorrow
you don't know where that comes from you
didn't know that was going to arise you
didn't know that was going to be
compelling
all of this is compatible with some evil
genius in the next room just typing in
code into your experience just like this
okay let's give him the
uh oh my god i just forgot it was going
to be our anniversary in one week
thought right give him the cascade of
fear
uh give him give him this brilliant idea
for the thing he can buy that's going to
take him no time at all in this this you
know overpowering sense of relief
all of our experiences is compatible
with with the
the script already being written right
it's and i'm not saying the script is
written i'm not saying that
fatalism is you know is the right way to
look at this
but we just don't have even our most
deliberate voluntary action where we go
back and forth between two options
you know thinking about the reason for a
and then then reconsidering and going
to thinking harder about b and just
going eeny meeny miny moe
until the end of the hour however
laborious you can make it
there is a utter mystery at your back
finally promoting the thought or
intention
or ration rationale
that is most compelling and therefore
deliberate
behaviorally um
effective uh and
just this and this can drive
some people a little crazy so i i
usually preface
what i say about free will with the
caveat that if thinking about
your mind this way makes you feel
terrible well then
stop you know get you get off the ride
switch the channel you don't have to go
down this path
but for me and for for many other people
it's incredibly freeing
just to recognize this about the mind
because
one it re one you realize that you're i
mean
cutting through the illusion of the of
the self is immensely freeing for a lot
of reasons that
that we can talk about separately but
losing the sense of free will
does two things very vividly for me one
is it totally undercuts
the basis for psychological basis for
hatred
because when you when you think about
the experience of hating other people
what that is anchored to is a feeling
that they really
are the true authors of their actions i
mean that someone is doing something
that you find so despicable right let's
say they're you know targeting you
unfairly right they're maligning you on
twitter or they're
you know they're they're suing you or
they're doing something they broke your
car window they did something awful
and now you have a grievance against
them and you're relating to them
very differently emotionally in your own
mind
than you would if a force of nature had
done this right or if it's if it just
been you know a virus or if it had been
a wild animal
uh or a malfunctioning machine right
like to those things you don't attribute
any kind of freedom of will
and while you you may suffer the
consequences of
catching a virus or being attacked by a
wild animal or having a you know your
car
break down or whatever it may frustrate
you
you don't slip into this mode of hating
the agent in a way that completely
commandeers your
your mind and deranges your life i mean
you just don't i mean there are people
who spend
decades hating other people for
what they did and it's it's just pure
poison
so it's a useful shortcut to compassion
and empathy yeah yeah but the question
is
say that this call what was it the horse
of consciousness let's call it the uh
the consciousness generator black box
that we don't understand
and is it possible that the script
that we're walking along
that we're playing that's already
written is actually being written
in real time it's almost like you're
driving down a road
and in real time that road is being laid
down yeah and this black box of
consciousness that we don't understand
is the place where the script is being
generated
so it's not it is being generated it
didn't always exist
so there's something we don't understand
that's fundamental about the nature of
reality
that generates both consciousness let's
call it maybe
the self i don't know if you want to
distinguish between those yeah i
definitely would yeah
you would because there's a bunch of
illusions we're referring to there's the
illusion of free will
there's the illusion of self and there's
the illusion of consciousness
you're saying i think you said there's
no
you're not as willing to say there's an
illusion of consciousness
in fact i would say it's impossible
impossible you're a little bit more
willing to say that there's an illusion
of self
and you're definitely saying there's an
illusion of free will
yes yes and i'm definitely saying
there's an illusion that
a certain kind of self is an illusion
not every we mean many different things
by this notion of self
so maybe i should just differentiate
these things so
consciousness can't be an illusion
because
any illusion proves its reality as much
as any other vertical
perception i mean if you're
hallucinating now that's just as much of
a demonstration of consciousness as
really seeing what's
quote actually there if you're if you're
dreaming and you don't know it
you that is consciousness right if
you're you can be confused about
literally everything
you can't be confused about the
the underlying claim you know whether
you make it linguistically or not
but just the the the the cognitive
uh assertion that something
seems to be happening it's the seeming
that is is the cash value of
consciousness
can i take a tiny tangent okay so what
if
i am creating consciousness in my mind
to convince you that i'm human so it's a
useful
social tool not a fundamental
property of experience like
of being a living thing what if it's
just like a social tool
to to almost like a useful computational
trick
to place myself into reality as we
together communicate about this reality
and another way to ask that because you
said much earlier
you talked negatively about robots as
you often do so let me
because um you'll probably die first
when they take over yeah yeah um
no no i'm looking forward to certain
kind of robots i mean i'm not
if we can get this right this would be
amazing but you don't like the robots
that fake consciousness that's what you
you you don't like the idea of fake it
till you make it well no i
it's not that i don't like it it's that
i'm worried
that we will lose sight of the problem
and the problem has massive
ethical consequences if we if we create
robots that really can suffer
that would be a bad thing right and if
if we really are committing a murder
when we recycle them that would be a bad
thing that's how i know you're not
russian why is it a bad thing that would
create robots that can suffer
isn't suffering a fundamental thing from
which like beauty springs
like without suffering do you really
think we would have beautiful things in
this world
okay well that's a that's a tangent on a
tangent okay we'll go there i would love
to go there but let's not go there just
yet all right
but you know i do think it would be if
anything is bad creating
hell and populating it with
real minds that really can suffer in
that hell that's
you know that's bad you know that's the
the you are
you are worse than than any mass
murderer we can name
if you created i mean this could be in
robot former you know more likely it
would be in
in some similar simulation of a world
where we managed to populate it with
conscious minds so that we know whether
we knew they were conscious or not
and that world is is a state of you know
that's it's unendurable
um that would just it just taking the
thesis seriously that
there's nothing that mind
intelligence and consciousness
ultimately are substrate independent
right it doesn't you don't need a
biological brain to be conscious you
certainly don't need a biological brain
to be intelligent
right so if we just imagine the
consciousness at some point comes along
for the ride as you scale up in
intelligence
well then we could find ourselves
creating conscious minds
that are miserable right and that's just
like creating a person who's
miserable right it could be worse than
creating a person who's miserable could
be
even more sensitive to suffering cloning
them and maybe for entertainment
watching them suffer
just like watching a person for suffer
for entertainment
you know so but but back to your the
your primary question here which is
differentiating
differentiating consciousness and self
and free will as concepts and kind of
degrees of illusoriness
the problem with free will is that
what most people mean by it and that the
and you know and dan this is where dan
dennett is going to get off the ride
here right so like he he doesn't he's
going to disagree with me that i
that i know what most people mean by it
but i have a very uh
keen sense having talked about this
topic for
many many years and seeing people get
wrapped around the axle
of it and seeing seeing in myself what
it's like to have felt
that i was a self that had free will and
then to no longer feel that way right i
mean to know what it's like to actually
disabuse myself of that
uh sense cognitively and emotionally
and to recognize what's left what goes
away and what doesn't go away
on the basis of that epiphany i have a
sense that i know
what people think they have in hand when
they worry about whether free will
exists and it
is the it is the flip side of this
feeling of self it's the flip side of
feeling like you are not merely
identical
to experience you feel like you're
having an experience
you feel like you're an agent that is
appropriating an experience there is a
protagonist in the movie of your life
and it is you
it's not just the movie right it's like
the the
every like their sights and sounds and
sensations and thoughts and emotions and
this whole cacophony of experience a
felt experience a felt experience of
embodiment
but there seems to be a
a rider on the horse or a passenger in
the body
right people don't feel truly identical
to their bodies down to their toes
they sort of feel like they have bodies
they feel like their minds
in bodies and that feels like
a self that feels like me and
again this gets very paradoxical when
you talk about
the experience of of being in
relationship to yourself or talking to
yourself you know giving yourself a pep
talk i mean if you're the one talking
why are you also the one listening like
why do you need the pep talk and why
does it work
if you're the one giving the pep talk
right yeah or like or if i said like
where are my keys right if i'm looking
for my keys
why do i think the superfluous thought
where are my keys
i know i'm looking for the [ __ ] keys
i'm the one looking who am i telling
that you know that we now need to look
for the keys right so that duality is
weird but
leave that aside there's
the sense so and this this becomes very
vivid when people
try to learn to meditate you know most
people
they start by they start they close
their eyes and they're told to pay
attention to an object like the breath
say so you close your eyes and you pay
attention to the breath
and you can feel it at the tip of your
nose or the rising falling of your
abdomen
and you're you're paying attention and
you feel something vague there
and then you think i thought why the
breath why am i
why am i paying attention to the breath
what's what's so special about the
breath
and then you then you then you notice
you're thinking and you're not paying
attention to the breath anymore and then
you
then you realize okay the practice is
okay i should notice thoughts and then i
should come back to the breath
but this starting point is the of the
conventional starting point of feeling
like you're an agent
very likely in your head a locus of
consciousness a locus of attention
that can strategically pay attention to
certain parts of experience like i can
focus on the breath
and then i get lost in thought and now i
can come back to the breath
and i can open my eyes and i can i'm
over here behind my face
looking out at a world that's other than
me and there's this kind of subject
object perception
and that is the default starting point
of selfhood of subjectivity
and married to that
is the sense that i can decide
what to do next right i am i am an agent
who can pay attention to the cup
i can listen to sounds there are certain
things that i can't control certain
things are happening to me and i just
can't control them so for instance
if someone asks well can you not hear
a sound right like don't hear the next
sound don't hear anything for a second
or don't hear
don't hear i'm you know i'm snapping my
fingers don't hear this where's your
free will you know will i just stop this
from coming in
you you you realize okay wait a minute
my my abundant freedom does not
extend to something as simple as just
being able to pay attention to something
else
than this um okay well so that i'm not
that kind of free agent but
at least i can decide what i'm going to
do next and i'm going to
i'm going to pick i'm going to pick up
this water right
and there's a feeling of identification
with the impulse with the intention with
the thought that occurs to you with the
with the feeling of speaking like you
know what am i what am i going to say
next well i'm saying it so here goes
this is me i it feels like i'm the
thinker i'm the
i'm the one who's in control
but all of that is born of not really
paying close attention
to what it's like to be you and and so
this is
this is where meditation comes in or
this is where um
again you can get you can get at this
conceptually
you can unravel the notion of free will
just by by
thinking certain certain thoughts but
you can't
feel that it doesn't exist unless you
can pay
close attention to how thoughts and
intentions arise
so the way to unravel it conceptually is
just to realize okay
i didn't make myself i didn't make my
genes i didn't make my brain i didn't
make the
the environmental influences that
impinged upon this system for the last
54 years
that have produced my brain in precisely
the state
it's in right now such with all of the
the receptor weightings and densities
and
you know it's just i'm i'm exactly the
machine i am right now through
no fault of of
my own as the experiencing itself i get
no credit and i get no blame
for the genetics and the enviro the
environmental influences here
and yet those are the only things that
could contrive to
to produce my next thought or impulse
or or moment of behavior and if you were
going to add something magical to that
clockwork like an immortal soul
you can also notice that you didn't
produce your soul rightly you you can't
account for the fact that you don't have
the soul
of someone who doesn't like any of the
things you like
or wasn't interested in any of the
things you were interested in or you
know or
was a psychopath or was either you had
an iq of 40 or like there's nothing
nothing about that that the person who
believes in us
in a soul can claim to have controlled
and yet that is
also totally dispositive of whatever
happens next
and but everything you've described now
maybe you can correct me but it kind of
speaks to the materialistic
nature of the hardware
but even if you add magical ectoplasm
software
you didn't you didn't produce that
either i i know but
if we can think about the actual
computation
running on the hardware and running on
the software there's something you said
recently
which you think of um culture as an
operating system
so if we just remove ourselves a little
bit
from the conception of human
civilization being a collection of
humans
and rather us just being a distributed
uh computation system on which there's
some kind of operating system running
and then the computation that's running
is the actual thing that generates
the interactions the communications and
maybe even free will the experiences of
all those free will
do you ever think of do you ever try to
reframe the world in that way where it's
like
ideas are just using us thoughts
are using individual nodes in the system
and they're just jumping around and they
also have ability to generate like
experiences
so that we can push those ideas along
and basically
the main organisms here are the thoughts
not the humans
yeah but then that erodes the boundary
between
self and world right so so then there's
no
self really a really integrated self to
have
any kind of will at all like if you're
just a meme
plex i mean if there's just like if if
you're just a collection of memes
yeah and i mean like we're all kind of
like like currents like eddies in in
in this river of of ideas right so
it's like um and it seems to have
structure
but there's no real boundary between
that part of the flow of water
and the rest i mean if our and i would
say that much of our mind answers to
this kind of description i mean
so much of our mind has been
[Music]
it's obviously not self-generated and
it's not it's not going to find it by
looking in the brain
it's it is the result of
culture largely but also um
uh you know it's it's the genes on one
side and culture on the other
m meeting to allow for
um manifestations of mind that don't
that aren't actually bounded by the the
person
in any clear sense it was just
the example i often use here but
there are so many others is just the
fact that we're following
the rules of english grammar to whatever
degree we are
it's not that we certainly haven't
consciously represented these
rules for ourselves we haven't invented
these rules
we haven't i mean there are there are
norms of
language use that we couldn't even
specify because we haven't you know
we're not grammarians we're not we
haven't studied this
we don't even have the right concepts
and yet we're following these rules and
we're noticing
you know we're noticing as you know an
error when we fail to follow
these rules and
virtually every other cultural norm is
like that i mean these are not things
we've invented
you can you can consciously decide to to
scrutinize them and override them but
i mean just think of just think of any
social situation where you're with other
people
and you're behaving in ways that are
culturally
appropriate right you're not being you
know you're not being
wild animals together you're following
you have some expectation of
how you shake a person's hand and how
you
um deal with with implements on a table
how you have a meal together
obviously this can change from culture
to culture and
and people can be shocked by how
different those things are right we you
know we
all have foods we find disgusting but in
some countries
dog is not one of those foods right and
and yet you know you and i presumably
would be
horrified to be served dog
those are not norms that we're
they are outside of us in some way and
they're
yet they're they're felt very viscerally
i mean they're
certainly felt in their violation you
know if you're if you
are just imagine you're you're in
somebody's home you're eating something
that tastes great to you
and you happen to be in vietnam or
wherever you know you you
didn't realize dog was potentially on
the menu and
you find out that you've just eaten 10
bites of what
is uh you know really a cocker spaniel
and
you feel this instantaneous urge to
vomit
right based on an idea right like so
like you did not
you're not the author of that norm
that gave you such a powerful experience
of its violation
and i'm sure we can trace the moment in
your history
you know vaguely where it sort of got in
i mean very early on as kids you you
realize you're
you're treating dogs as pets and not as
food or as potential food
but yeah no it's but
the point you just made opens us
to like we are totally permeable to a
sea of mind yeah but
if we uh take the metaphor of the
distributed computing systems
each individual node is
is part of performing a much larger
computation
but nevertheless is in charge of doing
the scheduling
of uh so assuming it's linux is doing
the scheduling of processes and it's
constantly alternating them that node is
making those uh
choices that node sure as hell believes
it has free will
and actually has free will because it's
making those hard choices
but the choices ultimately are part of
much larger computation that it can't
control
isn't it possible for that node to still
be that human node
uh is still making the choice well
it is so i'm not saying that your body
isn't doing really doing things right
and
some of those things can be
conventionally thought of as choices
right so it's like i can i can choose to
reach and
it's like it's not being imposed on me
that would be a different experience
like so there's a
there's an experience of of all you know
there's there's definitely a difference
between voluntary and involuntary action
there's uh so we that has to get
conserved by any account of the mind
that that jettison's free will you still
have to admit that that
there's a difference between a tremor
that i can't control
and a a purposeful motor action that i
can control and i can initiate on demand
and it's associated with intentions
uh and i've it's got efferent uh
you know motor copy which which is being
which is being predictive so that i can
notice errors you know i have
expectations when i reach for this
if my hand were actually to pass through
the bottle because it's a hologram
i would be surprised right so that shows
that i have a expectation of just
what my grasping behavior is going to be
like even before it happens
whereas with a tremor you don't have the
same kind of thing going on
that's a distinction we have to make so
i am yes i'm
really the proxy my intention
to move subject which is in fact can be
subjectively felt really is the
proximate cause of my moving it's not
coming from
elsewhere in the universe i'm not saying
that
so in that sense the node is really
deciding to execute
you know the the subroutine now
but um that's not
the feeling that has given rise to this
this conundrum of free will right so the
the people feel like
people feel like they the crucial things
that people feel like they could have
done otherwise right that's the
that's the thing that says that when you
when you run back the clock of your life
right you run back the movie of your
life you flip back the few pages in the
novel of your life
they feel that at that at this point
they could behave differently than they
did right so like
like but but given you know even given
your distributed computing example
it's either a determining a fully
deterministic system or it's a
deterministic system that admits of some
random
you know influence in either case
um that's not the free will people think
they have the p the free will people
think they have is
damn i shouldn't have done that i i just
like i i shouldn't have done that
i could have done otherwise right i
should have done otherwise right like if
i i
like if you think about something that
you deeply regret doing
right or that you do you hold someone
else responsible for
because they really are the upstream
agent in your mind of what they did
you know that's an awful thing that that
person did and they shouldn't have done
it
there is this illusion and it has to be
an illusion because there's there's no
picture of causation that would make
sense of it
there's this illusion that that if you
arrange the universe exactly the way it
was a moment ago
it could have played out differently and
the only way it could have played out
differently
is if there's randomness added to that
but
randomness isn't what people feel would
give them free will
right if you tell me that you know i i
only reach for the water bottle this
time
because somebody's because there's a
random number generator in there
kicking off values and it finally moved
my hand
that's not the feeling of authorship
that's still not control
you're still not making that decision
there's actually i don't know if
you're familiar with cellular automata
it's a really nice visualization of
how simple rules can create incredible
complexity that
it's like really dumb initial conditions
to set simple rules applied
and eventually you watch this thing and
if
the rule if the initial conditions are
correct that you're going to
have emerge something that to our
perception system looks like organisms
interacting
you can construct any kinds of worlds
and they're not actually interacting
it's not they're not actually even
organisms and they certainly
don't aren't making decisions so there's
like systems you can create that
illustrate this point
the question is whether there could be
some
room for let's use in the 21st century
the term magic
back to the black box of consciousness
let me ask you
it this way if you're wrong about your
intuition about
free will what and somebody comes along
to you and proves
to you that you didn't you didn't have
the full picture
what would that proof look like what
would uh well that's that's the problem
that's why it's not even an illusion
in in my world because it's
for me it's impossible to say what the
universe would have to be like
for free will to be a thing right it's
just it doesn't conceptually map onto
any notion of causation we have
and that's unlike any other
spurious claim you might make so like if
you're gonna
if you're gonna believe in ghosts right
i understand what that claim could be
or like i you know i don't happen to
believe in ghosts but
if it's it's not hard for me to specify
what would have to be true for ghosts to
be real
and so it is with a thousand other
things like ghosts right so like
okay so you're telling me that when
people die there's some part of them
that is not reducible at all to their
biology that lifts off them
and goes elsewhere and is actually the
kind of thing that can linger in closets
and in cupboards and
and actually it's immaterial but by some
principle of physics we don't totally
understand
it can make sounds and knock you know
objects
and even occasionally show up so they
can be visually beheld
um and it's just it seems like a miracle
but it's just this is just
some spooky noun in the universe that we
don't understand
let's call it a ghost that's fine i can
talk about that all day that the reasons
to believe in it the reasons not to
believe in it the way we would
scientifically test for it what would
have to be provable
so as to convince me that ghosts are
real
free will isn't like that at all there's
no description
of any concatenation of causes that
precedes
my conscious experience that sounds like
what people think they have
when they think they could have done
otherwise and that they really that they
the conscious agent
is really in charge right like if you
don't know what you're going to think
next
right and you can't help but think it
take those two premises on board
you don't know what it's going to be you
can't stop it
from coming and until you actually
know how to meditate you can't stop
yourself from
fully living out its behavioral or
emotional consequences
right like you have no you you once you
mindfulness you know
arguably gives you a another degree of
freedom here
it doesn't give you free will but it
gives you some other game to play with
respect to
the the the emotional and behavioral
imperatives of thoughts
but short of ev
short of that i mean the reason why
mindfulness doesn't give you free will
is because you can't
you know you can't account for why in
one moment mindfulness arises
and and in other moments it doesn't
right but
um but a pro a different process is
initiated once you can
can practice in that way well if i could
push back for a second by the way i just
had this thought bubble come
popping up all the time of just two
recent chimps arguing about the nature
of consciousness
it's kind of hilarious so on that thread
right you know
if we're even before einstein let's say
before einstein we were
to conceive about traveling from point a
to point b
say some point in the future we are able
to realize through engineering
a way which is suppose is consistent
with einstein's theory that you can have
wormholes you can travel from one point
to another
faster than the speed of light
and that would i think completely change
our conception what it means to travel
in the physical space and that like
completely transform our ability
you talk about causality but here let's
just focus on
what it means to travel through physical
space don't you think it's
possible that there will be inventions
or leaps in understanding about reality
that will allow us to see free will as
actually like us humans
somehow may be linked to this idea of
consciousness
are actually able to be authors of our
actions
it is a it's a non-starter for me
conceptually
it's a little bit like saying
could there be some breakthrough that
will cause us to realize that
circles are really square or the circles
are not really round
right no a circle is what we mean
by a perfectly round form right like
it's it's it's
it it's not it's not on the table to be
revised and
so i would say the same thing about
consciousness so it's just like saying
is there some breakthrough that would
get us to realize
that consciousness is really an illusion
i'm saying
no because what the experience of an
illusion
is as much a demonstration of what i'm
calling consciousness as anything else
right like that that is consciousness
um with free will it's a similar problem
it's like um
again it comes down to a picture of
causality and there's just there's no
there's no other picture on offer and
what's more
i know i know what it's like on the
experiential side
to lose the thing to which it is clearly
anchored
right like the feel like it doesn't feel
and this is and this is the question
that almost nobody asked
people who are debating me on on the
topic of free will
i i'm you know at 15 minute intervals
i'm making a claim
that i don't feel this thing and they
are never become interested in
well what's that like like okay so
you're actually saying you don't
you this this thing isn't you know isn't
true for you empirically it's not just
because
most people who who don't believe in
free will
philosophically also believe that we're
condemned to experience it like they
you just you can't live without this
feeling so
so you're actually saying you're able to
experience
the absence of
the illusion of free will yes yes for
are we talking about
whenever whenever minutes at a time or
um is this to require a lot of work and
meditation are you
literally able to load that into your
mind and like play that
right now right now just in this
conversation so
it's not it's not absolutely continuous
but it's whenever i pay attention it's
like
it's the same and i would say the same
thing for the the illusoriness of the
self in the sen and again we
we haven't talked about this so can you
still have the self and not have the
free will never mind
at the same time do they go at the same
time this is the same yeah it's the same
thing that they're always holding hands
when they walk out the door i mean
there really are two sides of the same
coin okay but it's just it comes down to
what it's like
to try to get to the end of this
sentence or what it's like to
to finally decide that it's been long
enough and now i need another sip of
water right if i'm paying attention now
if
i'm not paying attention i'm probably
i'm captured by some other thought and
that feels a certain way
right and so that's not it's not vivid
but if i try to make vivid
this experience of just okay i'm finally
going to experience free will i'm going
to notice my free will
right like it's got to be here
everyone's talking about it
where is it i'm going to pay attention
to i'm going to look for it and i'm
going to
i'm going to create a circumstance that
is is where it is it has to be most
robust right i'm not rushed to make this
decision
i'm not it's not a reflex i'm not under
pressure
i'm gonna take as long as i want i'm
going to decide
it's not trivial like so it's not just
like reaching with my left hand to reach
with my right hand people don't like
those examples for some reason
let's make a big decision like
where should you know
what should my next podcast be on right
who do i invite on the next
podcast what is it like to make that
decision
when i pay attention there is no
evidence of free will
anywhere in sight it's like it doesn't
feel like it feels
profoundly mysterious to be to be going
back between two people you know
like is it going to be person a or
person b
i've got all my reasons for a and all my
reasons why not and all my reasons for
be
and that there's some math going on
there that i that i'm not
not even privy to where certain concerns
are trumping others
and at a certain point i just decide
and yes you can say i'm the node in the
network that has made that decision
absolutely i'm not saying it's being
piped to me from elsewhere
but the feeling of what it's like to
make that decision
is
totally without a
sense a real sense of
agency because because something
simply emerges it's literally it's
literally as tenuous as
what's the next sound i'm going to hear
right or what's a what's the next
thought that's going to appear
and it just something just appears you
know and and if something appears to
cancel that something
like if i say i'm going to invite her
and then i'm about to send the email and
i think oh no no i can't
i can't do that there was a thing in the
that
new york article i read that i got to
talk to this guy right
that pivot at the last second you can
make it as as
muscular as you want it always just
comes out of the darkness
it's always mysterious so right when you
try to pin it down you really can't ever
find that
free will it's the the the the
if you construct an experiment for
yourself and you're trying to really
find that moment when you're actually
making that
controlled author decision it's it's uh
and we're still we're still we know at
this point that if we were scanning your
brain
in some ex you know podcast guest
choosing experiment right we know
at this point we would be privy to who
you're
going to pick before you are you the
conscious agent if we could again this
is
operationally a little hard to conduct
but there's enough data now
to know that something very much like
this cartoon
is in fact true um and will ultimately
be undeniable for people
um they'll be able to do it on
themselves with their you know some app
um
if you're deciding what to you know
where to go for dinner or who to have on
your podcast or ultimately you know who
to marry right or what what city to move
to
right like you you can make it as big or
as small a decision as you want
we could be scanning your brain in real
time and
at a point where you still think you're
uncommitted
we would be able to say with arbitrary
accuracy
all right lex is he's moving to austin
right i didn't choose that yeah he was
true it was it was going to be austin it
was going to be miami he got
he's catching one of these two waves but
it's going to be austin
and at a point where you subjectively if
we if we could ask you
you would say oh no i'm still i'm still
working over here
i'm still thinking i'm still choosing
i'm still considering my options
and you've spoken to this in you
thinking about other stuff in the world
it's been very useful
to uh to step away from this illusion of
free will
and you argue that it's probably makes a
better world because you can be
compassionate and empathetic towards
others
and towards oneself
radically toward others in that
literally
hate makes no sense anymore i mean there
are certain things you can
really be worried about really want to
oppose really i mean
i'm not saying you'd never have to kill
another person like i mean self-defense
is still a thing right
but the idea
that you're ever confronting anything
other than a force of nature
in the end goes out the window right or
what does go out the window when you
really pay attention i'm not i'm not
saying that this
would be easy to under to grok
if you know
you know someone kills a member of your
family i'm not saying you can just
listen to my 90 minutes on free will and
then you should be able to see that
person as identical to a
grizzly bear or or a virus
because it's so i mean we are so evolved
to uh deal with one another as
as fellow primates and as agents uh
but it's um yeah when you're talking
about the possibility of
you know christian you know truly
christian
forgiveness right it's just like
as as testified to by you know various
um
uh saints of that flavor over the over
the
the millennial yeah
that is that the doorway to that is to
recognize
that no one really at bottom made
themselves
right and and therefore everyone what
we're seeing really
are differences in luck in the world
we're seeing people who are
very very lucky to have had good parents
and good genes and to be in good
societies and good opportunities
and to be intelligent and to be you know
not sociopathic like
it's none of it is on them they're just
reaping one lot
the the fruits of one lottery after
another and then
showing up in the world on that basis
and then so it is with you know every
malevolent [ __ ] out there right he
he or she didn't make themselves
even if that weren't possible the
utility for
for self-compassion is also enormous
because it's when you just look at what
it's like
to regret
something or to feel shame about
something or feel deep embarrassment
these states of mind are some of the
most
deranging experiences anyone has and and
they're reactive
the the kind of the the indelible
reaction
to them you know the memory of the thing
you said the you know the memory of the
wedding toast you gave
20 years ago that was just mortifying
right the fact that that can still
make you hate yourself right and like
like that
psychologically that is a knot that can
be untied
right speak for yourself sam yeah yeah
clearly you gave a great
great toast it was my toast that
mortified no no that's not what i was
referring to i
i i'm deeply appreciative
in the same way that you're referring to
of every moment i'm alive
but i'm also powered by self-hate often
like several things in this conversation
already that i've spoken
i'll be thinking about like that was the
dumbest thing
you're sitting in front of sam harris he
said that
so like that but that somehow creates a
richer experience for me like i've
actually come to accept that as a nice
feature of however my
brain was built i don't think i want to
let go of that
well the thing you i think the thing you
want to let go of is
uh the suffering
associated with it so like so for me so
so
mr psychologically and ethically all of
this is very interesting
so i don't think we ever we should ever
get rid of things like anger
right so like hatred is hatred is
divorceable from anger
in the sense that hatred is this
enduring state
where you know whether you're hating
somebody else or hating yourself
it is just it is toxic and durable
and ultimately useless right like it
becomes it becomes self
nullifying right like you become less
capable as a person to solve any of your
problems it's not it's not instrumental
in solving the problem that is
that is is occasioning all this hatred
and anger for the most part isn't either
except as a
signal of salience that there's a
problem right so if somebody does
something that makes me angry
that just promotes this situation to to
conscious
uh conscious attention in a way that is
stronger than
my not really caring about it right and
there are things that i think should
make us angry in the world
and there the there's the behavior of
other people that should make us angry
because we should respond to it and so
it is with yourself if i do something
you know as a parent if i do something
stupid that harms one of my daughters
right um my belief
my experience of myself and my beliefs
about free will
closed the door to my saying well i
should have done otherwise in the sense
that if i
could go back in time i would have
actually effectively done otherwise
no i would do given the same causes and
conditions i would do that thing a
trillion times in a row right
but you know
regret and feeling bad about an outcome
are still important to capacities
because like yeah you're like
i i desperately want my daughters to be
happy and healthy
so if i if i've done something you know
if i if i crash the car when they're in
the car and they get injured right
because and i'm
i do it because i was trying to change
the song on my playlist or you know
something stupid
i'm going to feel like a total [ __ ]
how long do how long do i stew in that
feeling of regret right and
like what utility is there to extract
out of this error signal
and then what do i do we're always faced
with the question of what to do next
right and and and how
to best do that thing that necessary
thing next
and how much well-being
can we experience while doing it like
how much how miserable do you need to be
to solve your problems in life and to
solve the problems of
to help solve the problems of people
closest to you you know how
how miserable do you need to be to get
through your to-do list today
ultimately i think you can be
deeply happy going through all of it
right and not and and even navigating
moments that are scary
and you know really destabilizing to
ordinary people and
um i mean i think you know again
i'm i'm always up kind of at the edge of
my own capacities here and there
all kinds of things that stress me out
and worry me and i'm especially
something if it's
you're going to tell me it's something
with you know the health of one of my
kids
you know it's very hard for me like it's
very hard for me to to be truly
equanimous
around that but equanimity is so
useful the moment you're in in response
mode
right because it's the the the ordinary
experience
for me of responding to what seems like
a medical emergency for one of my kids
is to be obviously super
energized by concern to respond to that
emergency
but then once i'm responding all of my
fear
and agitation and worry and oh my god
what if this is really
something terrible but
finding any of those thoughts compelling
all that only diminishes my capacity as
a father
to be good company while we navigate
this really turbulent
passage you know as you're saying this
actually one guy comes to mind which is
elon musk
one of the really impressive things to
me was to
observe how many dramatic things he has
to deal with throughout the day
at work but also if you look through his
life family too
and how he's very much actually as
you're describing
basically a practitioner of this way of
thought which is
you're not in control you're
basically responding no matter how
traumatic the event and there's no
reason to sort of linger on the
well yeah i think the negative feelings
are on that well so i mean he but he's
in a very
specific situation which is
which is unlike
normal life you know even his normal
life but normal life for for most people
because
when you just think of like you know
he's running so many businesses and he's
he's
they're very they're not they're
non-highly non-standard businesses
so what he's seen is everything that
gets to him
is some kind of emergency like it
wouldn't be getting to him if it needs
his attention
there's a fire somewhere so exactly so
he's constantly responding to
fires that have to be put out so
there's no default expectation that
there shouldn't be a fire
right but in our normal lives we live
most of
most of us who are lucky right not
everyone obviously on earth but
most of us who are at some kind of
cruising altitude
in terms of our lives where we're
reasonably healthy and that life is
reasonably orderly and the political
apparatus around us is reasonably
functionable functional
um functionable so i said functionable
for the first time in my life through no
free will of my own see like i notice
those errors
and they do not feel like like like
agency
and nor does nor does the success of an
utterance feel like agency
he when you're when you're looking at
normal human life
right where you're you're just trying to
be happy
and healthy and get your work done
there's this default expectation that
there shouldn't be fires people
shouldn't be getting sick
or injured you know the the we shouldn't
be losing
vast amounts of our resources we should
like so
when something really stark like that
happens
people don't have a people don't have
that muscle
that they've like i've been responding
to emergency emergencies all day long
you know seven days a week in business
mode and so i have a very thick skin
this is just another one what was i i'm
not expecting anything else when i wake
up in the morning
no we have this default sense that
i mean honestly most of us have the
default sense that we
aren't going to die right or that we
should like maybe we're not going to die
right like death denial really is a
thing
you know we're we we're because and you
can see it
just like i can see when i reach for
this bottle
that i was expecting it to be solid
because when it isn't solid when it's a
hologram and i just
my fist closes on itself i'm
damn surprised people are damn surprised
to find out that they're going to die to
find out that they're sick to find out
that someone
that they love has died or is going to
die
so it's like the the fact that we are
surprised by any of that shows us that
we're we're living at a
uh we're living in a mode that is um
you know we're perpetually diverting
ourselves from some
facts that should be obvious right and
that
and the more the more salient we can
make them uh you know the more
i mean in the case of death it's a
matter of of being able to get one's
priorities straight i mean
the moment again this is hard for
everybody even
those who are really in the business of
paying attention to it but
the moment you realize that every
circumstance is finite
right you you've got a certain number of
you know you've got whatever
whatever it is 8 000 days left in a
normal span of life
um and 8 000 is a sounds like a big
number it's not that big a number
right so it's just like and then you
then you can decide
how you want to go through life uh and
how you want to experience each one of
those days
and so i was back to where our jumping
off point
i would argue that you don't want to
feel
self-hatred ever i i i would argue that
you don't want to
really
really grasp on to any of those moments
where you where you
are take or internalizing the fact that
you just made an error
you embarrassed yourself that something
didn't go the way you wanted it to
i think you want to you want to treat
all of those moments very very lightly
you want to extract
the the actionable information it's
something to learn oh
you know i i learned that when i
when i prepare in a certain way it works
better than i when i prepare in some
other way or don't prepare right like so
like
yes lesson learned you know and and do
that differently
but um
yeah i mean so many so many so many of
us have spent so much time
with a very uh
dysfunctional and hostile and even
hateful inner voice governing a lot of
our
self-talk and a lot of just just our
default way of being with ourselves i
mean the privacy of our own minds
we're in the company of of a real jerk
a lot of the time and um
and that that can't help but affect i
mean forget about just your your own
sense of well-being it can't help
but limit what you're capable of in the
world with other people
i'll have to really think about that i
just take pride that my jerk my inner
voice jerk
is much less of a jerk than like
somebody like david goggins who's like
screaming in his ear constantly so my
i just i have a relativist kind of
perspective that
it's not as bad as that at least well
having a sense of humor
also helps you know it's just like it's
not the stakes are
never quite what you think they are and
even when they are i mean
just the difference between see
being able to see the comedy of it
rather than because
again there's this sort of dark star of
self-absorption
that pulls everything into it right and
it's like if if that that's the that's
the algorithm
that's the algorithm you don't want to
run so it's like you just want
you just want things to be good so like
just push push the concern
out there like like the like the not
have the collapse
of oh my god what does this say about me
it's just like let's what does this say
about
how do we make this meal that we're all
having together as
as as fun as pun and as useful as
possible
and you're saying in terms of propulsion
systems you recommend humor as a good
spaceship to escape the gravitational
field of the
of that darkness well that certainly
helps yeah yeah yeah
well uh let me ask you a little bit
about ego and fame
which is very interesting the way you're
talking
given that you're one of the
biggest intellects living intellects and
minds
of our time and there's a lot of people
that really love you
and um almost uh elevate you to a sort
of certain kind of status where you're
like the guru
i'm surprised he didn't show up in a
robe in fact um
is there a hoodie that's that's not the
highest status garment one can wear now
the socially acceptable version of the
of the robe if you're a billionaire
is there something you can say about
managing the effects of fame
on your own mind on the not creating
this
you know when you wake up in the morning
when you look about in the mirror
how do you get your ego not to
grow exponentially your conception of
salt to grow exponentially because
there's so many people feeding that
is there something to be said about this
it's really not hard
because i mean i i feel like i have a
pretty clear sense of my strengths
and weaknesses and i i don't feel like
it's
i mean i don't honestly i don't feel
like i suffer from much grandiosity uh
i mean i just have a you know there's so
many things i'm not good at there's so
many things i will
you know given the the remaining 8 000
days
at best i will never get good at
i would love to be good at these things
uh so it's just
it's easy to feel diminished by
comparison with the
the talents of others do you remind
yourself of all the things
that you're not competent in
is that i mean like they're just on
display for me every day that i
appreciate the
the talents of others but you notice
them i'm i'm sure stalin and hitler did
not notice
all the ways in which they were uh i
mean this is why
absolute power crap corrupts absolutely
is you stop noticing the things
in which you're ridiculous and wrong
right
yeah no i am not to compare you to yeah
yeah well i'm sure there's an
interstalling in there somewhere
uh well we all hopefully he'll carry a
babysitter wears better clothes
um and i'm not going to grow that
mustache
those concerns don't map they don't map
on to me for
a bunch of reasons but one is i also
have a very peculiar audience
like i i'm just you know
i've been appreciating this for a few
years but it's it's i'm just now
beginning to understand that there are
many people who have audiences of my
size or larger
that have a very different experience of
having an audience than i do
i have i have curated for better or
worse
a peculiar audience and
the net result of that is
virtually any time i say anything of
substance
something like half of my audience my
real audience not haters from outside my
audience but my audience
is just revolts over it right they just
like oh my god i can't believe you said
like you you're such a schmuck right
yeah
they revolt with rigor and intellectual
sophistication
or not or not but i mean but it's like
but but people who are like so
i mean the clearest case is you know i
haven't have whatever audience i have
and then trump
appears on the scene and i discover that
something like 20
of my audience just went straight to
trump and couldn't believe i didn't
follow them there they were just aghast
that i didn't see that trump was
obviously exactly what we needed for
for uh to steer the ship of state for
the next four years
uh and then four years beyond that so
like so that's one example so if so
whenever i said anything
about trump i would hear from people who
loved more or less everything else i was
up to and had for years
but everything i said about trump just
gave me pure pain from this this
quadrant of my audience
but then saying the same thing happens
when i say
something about the derangement of the
far left anything i say about
wokeness right or identity politics
same kind of punishment signal from us
again
people who are core to my audience like
i've read all i read all your books
i'm using your meditation app i love
what you
say about science and but you are so
wrong about politics and you're
you know i'm starting to think you're a
racist [ __ ] for everything you said
about about
identity politics and there's so many
the free will topic is just like this
it's like
just they love what i'm saying about
consciousness and the mind and they love
to hear me talk about physics with
physicists and
it's all good this free will stuff is i
cannot believe you don't see how wrong
you are what a [ __ ] embarrassment you
are
so but i'm starting to notice that there
are other people
who don't have this experience of having
an audience because they have
just take the trump woke dichotomy they
just
castigated trump the same way i did but
they never say anything
bad about the far left so they never get
this punishment signal or they or you
flip it they
they they're all about the insanity of
critical race theory now they'll they we
we connect all those dots the same way
but they never really specified what was
wrong with trump
or they thought there was a lot right
with trump and they they
got all the pleasure of that and so they
have much more homogenized
audiences and so my
my experience is so just to come back to
you know this experience
of fame or quasi fame i mean it's true
and truth is not
real fame but it's it's still there's an
audience there
um it is a
it's now an experience where basically
whatever i put out i notice a ton of
negativity
coming back at me and
it just it is what it is i mean now now
it's like i used to think
wait a minute there's got to be some way
for me to communicate more clearly here
so as not to get
this kind of lunatic response
from my own audience from like people
who are who are showing all the signs of
of of we've been here for years for a
reason right these are not just trolls
and so i think okay i'm going to take 10
more minutes and really just
tell you what it should be absolutely
clear about what's wrong with trump
right i've done this a few times but i
got i think i got to do this again
or wait a minute how are they not
getting
that these episodes of police violence
are so obviously different from one
another
that you can't describe all of them to
know yet another racist maniac on the
police force
you know killing someone based on his
racism
last time i talked spoke about this it
was pure pain but i
just got to try again now at a certain
point i i mean i'm starting to feel
like all right i just i have to be
i have to cease again it comes back to
this expectation that there shouldn't be
fires
right like i feel like if i could just
play my game
impeccably the people who actually care
what i think
will follow me when i
hit trump and hit free will and hit the
woke and hit
whatever it is what how we should
respond to the coronavirus you know i
mean
vaccines you know are they a thing right
like there's such derangement
in in our information space now that
i mean i guess you know some people
could be getting more of this than i
expect but i i just noticed that
you know many of our our friends who are
in the same game
have more homogenized audiences and
don't get i mean
they've they've successfully filtered
out the people who are going to
despise them on this next topic and i
you know i would i would imagine you are
have a different experience of having a
podcast than i do at this point i'm sure
you get
haters but i would imagine you're uh
you're more streamlined i actually don't
like the word haters because it kind of
presumes that it puts people in a bin
i think we're all have like baby haters
inside of us and we just apply them and
some people
enjoy doing that more than others for
particular periods of time
i think you're gonna almost see hating
on the internet as a video game that you
just play
and it's fun but then you can put it
down and walk away and uh no
i i certainly have a bunch of people
that are very critical i can
list all the ways but does it feel like
it on any given topic does it feel like
it's
an actual title surge where it's like 30
of your audience
and then the other 30 of your audience
from podcast to podcast
no that's happening to me all the time
now well i'm more with uh
i don't know what you think about this i
mean joe rogan doesn't read
comments or doesn't mean comments much
and the argument he made to me is that
he already has an like a self-critical
person inside like and i i i'm gonna
have to think about what you said in
this conversation but i have this
very harshly self-critical person inside
as well where i don't need more fuel i
don't need
there i know i do sometimes that's why i
check negativity
occasionally not too often i sometimes
need to like
put a little bit more like coals into
the fire but not too much
uh but i already have that self-critical
engine that keeps me in check
i just i wonder uh you know a lot of
people who
gain more and more fame lose that um
that ability to be self-critical i i
guess because they lose the audience
that can be critical towards them
you know i do follow joe's advice much
more than i ever have here like i i
don't look at comments very often and
i'm probably using
twitter you know
five percent as much as i used to i mean
i really just get in and out on twitter
um and spend very little time in my ad
mentions
um i but you know it does it in some
ways it feels like a loss because
occasionally i get i see something
super intelligent there like i mean i'll
check my twitter ad mentions and someone
will have said
oh have you read this article and it's
like man that was just
that was like the best article sent to
me in in a month right so it's like to
have not have looked and to not have
seen that
that's um that's a loss so but it does
um
at this point a little goes a long way
because i yeah it's not um
it's not that it for me
now i mean this this could sound like a
fairly
stalinistic immunity to criticism it's
not so much that these voices of hate
turn on my inner hater you know more
it's more that i just i get a what i
fear is a
false sense of
humanity like that like like i feel like
i'm too online
and online is selecting for this
performative outrage in everybody
everyone's you know signaling to an
audience when they trash you
and i get a dar i'm getting a
you know a misanthropic
you know cut of of just what it's like
out there
and because when you meet people in real
life they're great you know they're all
rather often great you know and um it
takes a lot
to have anything like a twitter
encounter in real life with a living
person
um and that's i i think it's much better
to to have that as one's
default sense of what it's like to be
with people than what one gets on
on social media or in on youtube common
threads
you've produced a special episode with
uh rob reed on your podcast recently
on how bioengineering of viruses is
going to destroy human civilization
so uh or could could one clears
sorry the confidence there but in the
21st century what do you think
especially after
having thought through that angle
what do you think is the biggest threat
to
the survival of the human species
i can give you the full menu if you'd
like yeah well no i i would i would put
i would put the biggest threat at the
at another level out kind of the meta
threat is
our inability to agree
about what the threats actually are and
and
and to converge on strategies for
responding to them
right so like i view covet as among
other things
a truly terrifyingly f
failed dress rehearsal for something far
worse
right covet is just about as benign as
it could have been
and still have been worse than the flu
when you're talking about a global
pandemic right it's just it's
you know it's going to kill a few
million people
or it looks like it's killed about three
million people maybe it'll kill
a few million more unless something gets
away from us with a
variant that's that's much worse or we
really don't play our cards right but
um i mean the general shape of it is
it's got you know somewhere around well
one percent
lethality and
whatever side of that number it really
is on in the end
it's not uh what
would in fact be possible and is in fact
probably inevitable
something with you know orders of
magnitude uh
more lethality than that and it's just
so obvious we are
totally unprepared right we are we are
running this epidemiological experiment
of
linking the entire world together and
then also
now per the podcast that rob reed did
uh democratizing the tech that will
allow us to do this
to engineer pandemics right and some
more and more people will be able to
engineer
synthetic viruses that will be
uh by the sheer fact that they would
have been engineered with malicious
intent
you know worse than covid and we're
still living in a in you know to speak
specifically about
the united states we have a country here
where we can't even agree
that this is a thing like that that
coveted i mean there's still people who
think that this is
basically a hoax designed to control
people
uh and it's stranger still there are
people who
will acknowledge that covet is real and
they'll look the they don't think the
deaths have been faked or mis
ascribed um
but they think that it
that they're far happier the prospect of
catching covid
than they are of getting vaccinated
for covet right they're not worried
about covert they're worried about
vaccines for covet right
and the fact that we just can't converge
in a
conversation that it has we've now had a
year to
to have with one another on just what is
the ground truth here
how what's happened why has it happened
what's the how safe is it to get covered
at
uh you know every you know in every
cohort in the population
and how safe are the vaccines and the
fact that there's still
a an air of mystery around all of this
for
much of our society does not bode well
when you're talking about solving any
other problem that may yet kill us but
do you think convergence grows when the
magnitude is a threat
so it's possible except i feel like we
have
tipped into because when when the threat
of covet
looked the most dire right when we had
when we were seeing reports from italy
that looked like you know the beginning
of a zombie movie right because it could
have been much much worse
yeah like this is like this is lethal
right like your icus are gonna fill up
in like you're 14 days behind us you're
going to cr
your medical system is is in danger of
collapse
lock the [ __ ] down we have people
refusing to to do anything sane
in the face of that like and people
fundamentally thinking
it's not going to get here right like or
that's who knows what's going on in
italy but it has no implications for
what's going to go on in new york
in a mere six days right and now it
kicks off in new york
and you got people in the middle of the
country thinking
it's no factor it's not it's that's just
big city
those are big city problems or they're
faking it or
i mean it just the layer of politics
has become so dysfunctional for us that
even in even in what in the presence of
a pandemic that looked legitimately
scary there in the beginning i mean
it's not to say that it hasn't been
devastating for everyone who's been
directly affected by it and
it's not said to say it can't get worse
but here you know for a very long time
we have known
that we were we're in a situation that
is more benign
than the what's what seemed like the
worst case scenario
as it was kicking off especially in
italy
um and
so still yeah it's quite possible that
if we saw the asteroid
hurtling toward earth and you know
everyone agreed that
it's going to it's going to make impact
and we're all going to die
then we could get off twitter and
actually
you know build the the rockets that are
going to divert the you know divert the
asteroid from its
earth crossing path and we could do
something pretty heroic but
when you talk about anything else that
isn't
um that's slower moving than that i mean
something like
climate change i think there's i think
the prospect of
of our converging
on a solution to climate change purely
based on political persuasion
is non-existent at this point i just
think that
i mean you know to bring elon back into
this the way to deal with climate change
is to
create technology that everyone wants
that is better
than all the the the carbon producing
technology
and then we just transition because you
want you want an
electric car the same way you wanted a
smartphone or you want anything else
and you're working totally with the
grain of people's
selfishness and short-term thinking
the idea that we're going to convince
the better part of humanity
that climate change is an emergency that
they have to make sacrifices
to respond to given what's happened
around covet i just think that's
that's a fantasy of a fantasy
but speaking of elon i have a bunch of
positive things that i want to say
here in response to you but you're
opening so many threads but let me pull
one of them which is uh ai
both you and and uh elon
think that with ai you're summoning
demons
summoning a demon maybe not in those
poetic terms but
well potentially potentially two very
three very parsimonious assumptions
i think here scientifically parsimonious
assumptions
get me there um
any of which could be wrong but it just
it seems like the
the weight of the the evidence is on
their side
one is that it comes back to this topic
of of
substrate independence right anyone
who's in the business of
producing intelligent machines must
believe
ultimately that there's nothing magical
about having a computer made of meat
you can do this in the kinds of you know
materials where
we're using now and
there's no special something that's that
that
that presents a a real impediment to
producing
human level intelligence in silico right
again an assumption either i'm sure
there are a few people who still think
there is something magical about
you know biological systems but
leave that aside
given that assumption and given the
assumption that we
just continue making incremental
progress it doesn't have to be moore's
law it just has to be progress that just
doesn't stop
at a certain point we'll get to the to
human level intelligence and beyond and
human level intelligence
i think is also clearly a mirage because
anything that's human level
is going to be superhuman by unless we
decide to dumb it down right i mean
my phone is already superhuman as a
calculator right so why would we make
the human level ai you know just as good
as me
a as a calculator so i think we'll
we'll very if we continue to make
progress
we will be in the presence of superhuman
competence for any
act of intelligence or cognition
that we care to prioritize it's not to
say that we
will create everything that a human
could do maybe we'll leave certain
things out
but anything that we care about and we
care about a lot
uh and we certainly care about anything
that that produces a lot of
power you know that we care about
scientific insights and
and inability to produce new technology
and all of that
um we'll have something that's
superhuman and then that
the final assumption is just that
there have to be ways to do that
that are not aligned with a happy
coexistence
with these now more powerful
entities than ourselves so and and i
would
i would guess and this is a you know
kind of a rider to that assumption
there are probably more ways to do it
badly than to do it
perfectly that is perfectly aligned
with our well-being and
when you think about the consequences of
of non-alignment
when you think about you're now
in the presence of something that is
more intelligent than you are
right which is to say more competent
right unless you've and and
obviously there are cartoon pictures of
this where we could just you know
this is just an off switch we can just
turn off the off switch or they're
tethered to something that that
makes them you know are slaves in
perpetuity even though they're more
intelligent but
that that strike those scenarios strike
me as a failure to imagine
what is actually entailed by greater
intelligence right so if you imagine
something that's
legitimately more intelligent than you
are
and you're now in relationship to it
right
you're in the presence of this thing and
it is autonomous in all kinds of ways
because it had to be to be more
intelligent than you are i mean you
built it to be
to be all of those things
we just can't find ourselves in a
negotiation
with something more intelligent than we
are you know and we can't
er so we have to have found the the
the subset of ways to build this these
machines
that are that are perpetually amenable
to are saying oh
that's not what we meant that's not what
we intended could you stop doing that
come back over here and do this thing
that we actually want
and for them to care for them to be
tethered to our own sense of our own
well-being
uh such that you know i mean their
utility function
is you know their primary utility
function is for is to have you know this
is
i think stuart russell's uh
you know cartoon uh
plan is to figure out how to to tether
them to a utility function that
that has our own estimation
of what's going to improve our
well-being as its
master you know reward
right so it's like that all that this
this thing can get as intelligent as it
can get
but it it only ever really wants to
figure out how to make our lives better
by our own view of better
now not to say there wouldn't be a
conversation about
you know i mean because of all kinds of
things we're not seeing clearly about
what
what is better and if we were in the
presence of a genie or an oracle
that could really tell us what is better
well then we should we presumably would
want to hear that and we would modify
our sense of
of of uh what to do next
in conversation with these with these uh
minds but
i just feel like it is a failure of
imagination
uh to think that
being in relationship in relationship to
something
more intelligent than yourself isn't in
most cases a circumstance of real
peril because because it is in in every
like just to think of
think of how everything on earth has to
if
they could think about their
relationship to us if birds could think
about
what we're doing right they would
i mean the bottom line is
they're always in danger of our
discovering that there's something we
care about more than birds
right or there's something we want that
disregards the
the well-being of birds and and you know
obviously
much of our behavior is inscrutable to
them occasionally we pay attention to
them and occasionally we withdraw our
attention
and occasionally we just kill them all
for reasons they can't possibly
understand
but we're if we're building something
more intelligent than ourselves by
definition we're building something
whose horizons of value
and and cognition can
exceed our own and and in ways where we
can't
necessarily foresee again perpetually
that they don't just wake up one day and
decide oh this these humans
need to disappear so i think i agree
with
most of the initial things you said what
i don't
necessarily agree with you my of course
nobody knows but
that the more likely set of trajectories
that we're going to take
are going to be positive that's what i
believe
in the sense that the way you develop
i believe the way you develop successful
ai systems will be deeply
integrated with human society and for
them to succeed
they're going to have to be aligned in
the way we humans are aligned with each
other
which doesn't mean we're aligned there's
no
such thing i don't see there's such
thing as a perfect alignment
but they're going to be participating in
the dance
in the game theoretic dance of human
society
and as they become more and more
intelligent there could be a point
beyond which we are like birds
to them but what about an intelligence
explosion of some kind so i i believe
the explosion
will be happening but it's
there's a lot of explosion to be done
before we become like birds
i i truly believe that human beings are
very intelligent in ways we don't
understand it's not just about chess
it's about
all the intricate computation we're able
to perform
common sense our ability to reason about
this world consciousness
i think we're doing a lot of work we
don't realize it's necessary to be done
in order to
truly become like truly achieve super
intelligence
and i just think there will be a period
of time that's not overnight
the overnight nature of it will not
literally be overnight
it'll be over a period of decades so my
sense is but why would it be that way
but just take
draw an analogy from successes like
something like alpha
go or alpha zero i forget the
the actual metric but it was something
like this algorithm
uh which wasn't even totally it wasn't
bespoke for chess playing
in the matter of i think it was four
hours played itself
so many times and so successfully that
it became the best chess playing
computer
not only was it was not only better than
every human being
it was better than every previous chess
program
in a matter of a day right so like that
like so just imagine
again we don't have to recapitulate
everything about us but just imagine
building a system
uh and who knows when we'll we'll be
able to do this but at some point we'll
be able
at some point the the 100 or 100
favorite things about human cognition
will be analogous to chess in that we
will be able to build machines
that very quickly outperform any human
and then very quickly outperform the
last
algorithm that perform outperform the
humans like something like the alphago
experience seems possible for
facial recognition and detecting human
emotion
and natural language processing right
like well it's just
it's it's just the way everyone you know
even math
people math heads tend to have bad
intuitions for
exponentiation right we noticed this
during covet and we have some very smart
people who
still couldn't get their minds around
the fact that
you know an exponential is is really
surprising i mean things double and
double and double and double again
and you don't notice much of anything
changes and then the last
you know two stages of doubling swamp
everything right and
um it just seems like that to assume
that there isn't a deep analogy between
what we're seeing for the more practical
the tractable problems like chess
to other modes of cognition it's like
once you
once you crack that problem it seems
because for the longest time
it was impossible to think we were going
to make headway on
in ai you know it's like chest and go
was the goal was seen as yeah
goes seemed unattainable even even when
chess had been cracked
go seemed unattainable yeah
and actually still russell was behind
the people that were saying it's
unattainable
right does it seem like uh you know it's
uh intractable problem
right but there's something different
about the space of
cognition that's detached from human
society which is what chess is
meaning like just thinking having
actual exponential impact on the
physical world is
is different i i tend to believe that
there's
for ai to get to the point where it's
super intelligent
it's going to have to go through the
funnel of
society and for that it has to be deeply
integrated with human beings
and for that it has to be aligned but
you're talking about like actually
hooking us up to like the neural link
you know we're going to be
the brain stem to the
robot overlords that's a possibility as
well but what i mean is
in order to develop autonomous weapons
systems for example
which are highly concerning to me that
both
us and china are participating in now
that
in order to develop them and for them to
become
to have more and more responsibility to
actually do
military military strategic actions
they're going to have to be
integrated into human beings
doing the strategic action they're going
to have to work alongside with each
other
and the way those systems will be
developed will have the natural
safety like switches that are placed on
them
as they develop over time because
they're going to have to convince humans
ultimately they're going to have to
convince humans that this is safer
than humans they're going to you know
eat well self-driving cars is a good
test case right here because like we're
obviously we're we've made a lot of
progress
and we can imagine
what total progress would look like i
mean it would be amazing and it's
answering
it's cancelling if in the us 40 000
deaths
every year based on ape-driven cars
right so we it's
a excruciating problem that we've all
gotten used to because it was no
alternative but now that we can dimly
see the prospect of an alternative which
if it works in a super intelligent
fashion
maybe we would go down to zero highway
deaths right or you know
certainly we go down by orders of
magnitude right so maybe we have
you know 400 rather than than 40 000
a year
and it's easy to see that there's not
and a missile so obviously this is not
an example of super intelligence this is
narrow intelligence but
um the the alignment problem isn't
so obvious there but there's there are
potential alignment problems
there like so like just just imagine if
some woke
team of engineers decided that
we have to tune the algorithm some way i
mean there are situations where the car
has to decide who to hit
i mean there's just bad outcomes where
you're going to hit somebody
right now we have a car that can tell
what race you are
right so we're going to build the car to
preferentially hit white people
because white people have had so much
privilege over the years this
seems like the only ethical way to kind
of redress those wrongs of the past
that's something that could get one that
could that could
get produced as an artifact presumably
of just how you built it and you didn't
even know you engineered it that way
right you you you cause machine learning
yeah you you put some kind of
constraints on it to where it creates
those kinds of options you
basically built a racist algorithm and
you didn't even intend to
or you could intend to right and it
would be aligned with some people's
values but misaligned with other
people's values
but it's like they're interesting
problems
even with something as simple and
obviously good as self-driving cars but
there's a leap
that i just think could be exact but
those are human problems
i just don't think there'll be a leap
with autonomous vehicles
first of all sorry there are
a lot of trajectories which will destroy
human civilization the argument i'm
making it's more likely
that we'll take trajectories that don't
so there i don't think there will be a
leap with autonomous vehicles will all
of a sudden start murdering pedestrians
because once every human on earth is
dead
there will be no more fatalities sort of
unintended consequences of
is difficult to take that leap i most
systems as we develop and they become
much much more intelligent
in ways that will be incredibly
surprising like stuff that's deep mind
is doing with protein folding
even which is scary to think about and
i'm personally terrified about this
which is the engineering of viruses
using machine learning
the engineering of uh vaccines using
machine learning right the engineering
of
uh yeah for research purposes pathogens
uh what you're using machine learning
like the ways that can go wrong
i just think that there's always going
to be a closed-loop
supervision of humans before they before
they
become super intelligent not always much
more likely to
to be supervision except of course
the question is how many dumb people are
in the world how many evil people are in
the world
my theory my hope is my
sense is that the number of intelligent
people is much higher than the number of
dumb people
that know how to program and the number
of evil people
i think smart people and kind people
over
outnumbered the others except we also we
had a
have to add another group of people
which are just the the smart
and otherwise good but reckless people
right the people who will
flip a switch on not knowing
what's going to happen they're just kind
of hoping that it's not going to blow up
the world
we already know that some of our
smartest people are those sorts of
people
you know we know we've done experiments
and this is something that martin reeves
was
whinging about before the large hadron
collider
got booted up i think we know there are
people who are
entertaining experiments or even
performing experiments where there's
some
chance you know not quite infinitesimal
uh that they're going to create a black
hole in the lab and suck every you know
the whole world into it right like that
that's not that's not
you're not a crazy person to worry that
i worry about that based on
on the physics and so it was with with
uh
you know the trinity test there were
some people who were still
checking their calculations and they
were off we've we did nuclear tests
where we
were off significantly in terms of the
yield right so it was like
and they still flip the switch yeah they
still flip the switch and and sometimes
they flip the switch not
to win a world war or to or to
save 40 000 lives a year they just just
just to see
intellectual curiosity like this is what
i got my grant for
this is this is where i'll get my nobel
prize if if uh that's in the cards
it's on the other side of this switch
right and
um i mean we again we are we are
apes with egos who are massively
constrained
by self very short-term self-interest
even when we're contemplating some of
the the deepest and most interesting and
most
um universal problems we could ever
set our attention towards i like just if
you read
james watson's book the double helix
right about the the
them you know cracking the the uh
structure of dna
one thing that's amazing about that book
is just how much of it
almost all of it is being driven
driven by
very apish uh egocentric
social concerns like that the algorithm
that is producing
this scientific breakthrough is human
competition
if you're james watson it's like i'm
going to get there before
linus pauling and you know
it's just it's so much of his bandwidth
is captured by that
right now that you know
that's that becomes that becomes more
and more of a liability when you're
talking about producing technology that
can change everything in an instant you
know we're talking about
not only understanding
you know we're just at a different
moment in human history we're not
when we're doing research
on viruses we're now doing the kind of
research
that can cause someone somewhere else to
be able to
to make that virus or weaponize that
virus or
or um it's just uh
i don't know i mean our power is our
wisdom
it does not seem like our wisdom is
scaling with our power right and like
that that seems like in so far and with
insofar
as wisdom and power become unaligned
i get more and more concerned but
speaking of
uh apes with the egos
uh some of the most compelling apes two
compelling apes i can think of as
yourself and jordan peterson and you've
had uh
fun conversation about religion that i
watched
most of i believe i'm not sure there was
any
um uh we didn't solve anything
if anything was ever solved so is there
something uh
like a charitable summary you can give
to the ideas
of that you agree on and disagree with
jordan is there something maybe after
that conversation that you've landed
where maybe uh
as as you both agreed on is there some
wisdom in the rubble
uh even of even um imperfect flawed
ideas
is there something that you can kind of
pull out from those conversations
or is it to be continued i mean i think
where we disagree so
he thinks that
many of our traditional religious
beliefs and frameworks
are holding so much
such a a repository of human wisdom
that we we
pull at that fabric
at our peril right like if you start
just unraveling
christianity or any other traditional
set of norms and
and beliefs you you may think you're
just pulling out the
unscientific bits but you could be
pulling a lot more
to which everything you care about is
attached
right as a society and
my feeling is that there's so much
there's so much downside to the
unscientific bits
and it's so clear how we could
have a 21st century rational
conversation about
the good stuff that we really can
radically edit
these traditions and we can take we can
take jesus
uh you know in in half his moods and
just find a great inspirational you know
you know thought iron age thought leader
you know who just happened to get
crucified but
he could be somewhat like you know the
beatitudes and
uh the golden rule which doesn't
originate originate with him but which
you know he put quite beautifully um
all of that's incredibly useful it's no
less useful than it was 2000 years ago
but we don't have to believe he was born
of a virgin or coming back to
raise the debt or any of that other
stuff and we can be honest about
not believing those things and we can be
honest about the reasons why we don't
believe those things
because i i on those fronts i view
the downside to be so obvious and the
these
the fact that we have so many different
competing dogmatisms on offer to be so
non-functional i mean it's so divisive
uh it's it just has
conflict built into it that i think we
can be
far more and should be far more
iconoclastic than
he wants to be right now none of this is
to deny
much of what he uh argues for that
that stories are very powerful i mean
clearly
stories are powerful and we want good
stories we want our lives
we want to have a conversation with
ourselves and with one another
about our lives that facilitates
the best possible lives and story is
part of that
right and if you want some of those
stories to
to s sound like myths that might be part
of it right but
my argument is that we never really need
to
deceive ourselves or our children about
what we have
every reason to believe is true in order
to get at the good stuff in order to
organize our lives well you know i
certainly don't feel that i need to do
it personally
and if i don't need to do it personally
why would i think that
billions of other people need to do it
personally right now
there's there is a cynical counter
argument which is
billions of other people don't have the
advantages that i have had in my life
you know the billions of other people
are not as well educated they haven't
had the same opportunities they have
they
they need to be told that
jesus is going to solve all their
problems after they die say
or that uh you know everything happens
for a reason
and you know just your if you just
believe in the secret if you just
visualize what you want you're going to
get it you know and and
it's like there's some some
some measure of what i consider to be
odious pablum
that really is food for the better part
of humanity and
and there is no substitute for it or
there's no substitute now
and i don't know if jordan would agree
with that but he much of what he says
seems to
suggest that he would agree with it um
and i guess that's an empirical question
i mean that's just that
we don't know whether given a different
set of norms and a different set of
stories
people would behave the way i would hope
they would behave and and be aligned
you know more aligned than they are now
i think we know what happens
when you just let ancient
religious certainties go uncriticized
we know what that world's like we've lit
we we've been struggling to get out of
that world for
a couple hundred years but we know what
you know
having europe uh
riven by religious wars looks like right
and we know what happens when those
religio when those religions become kind
of pseudo religions
and political religions right so this is
this is where i'm sure
jordan and i would debate he would say
that that you know
stalin was a symptom of atheism and
that's not at all i mean it's not my
kind of atheism right like
stalin the problem with with the gulag
and and the experiment with communism or
with stalinism
uh or with nazism was not that
there was so much scientific rigor and
self-criticism and honesty
and introspection and
you know judicious use of psychedelics i
mean
like that was not the problem in
hitler's germany
uh or in stalin's soviet union
the problem was you have other ideas
that capture a similar kind of
mob based dogmatic energy
and you know yes that's the
the results of all of that are are
predictably murderous
well the question is what is the source
of the
most viral and sticky stories
that ultimately lead to a positive
outcome so communism was
i mean having grown up in the soviet
union
even still you know having relatives
uh in in russia there's a stickiness to
the nationalism
and to the ideologies of communism that
religious or not
you could say it's religious for forever
i could just say it's
it's uh viral it's great it's stories
that are viral and sticky
i don't know i'm using the the most
horrible words but the question is
whether science
and reason can generate viral sticky
stories that give meaning to people's
lives
that's yeah it's in your senses it does
well whatever is true ultimately
should be captivating right it's like
what what's more
captivating than what is whatever is
real
right now it it's because
reality is again we're we're so
we're just climbing out of the darkness
you know in terms of our understanding
of what the hell is going on and there
and there's no telling
what spooky things may in fact be true i
mean i don't know if you've been on the
receiving end of
you know recent rumors about uh our
conversation about ufos
very likely changing in the near term
right but like there was just a
washington post article and a new yorker
article and
you know i've received some private
outreach and perhaps you have i
know other people in our our orbit have
people who are claiming that the
government has known much more about
ufos
than they have let on until now and
this conversation is actually is about
to become more prominent
you know and it's it's not going to be
whatever you know whoever's left
standing when the music stops
it's not going to be a comfortable
position to be in as a
super rigorous scientific skeptic saying
there's no there who's been saying
there's no there there for the last 75
years
all right you know like like the short
version is it
sounds like the office of naval
intelligence and the pentagon
are very likely to say to congress at
some point in the not too distant future
that
we have evidence that there is
technology
flying around here that seems
like it can't possibly possibly be of
human origin
all right now i don't know what i'm
gonna do with that kind of disclosure
right maybe it's just
it's gonna it's gonna be nothing no
follow-on conversation to really have
but that is such a
powerfully strange circumstance to be in
right i mean it's just what are we going
to do with that if in fact that's what
happens
right if in fact the the
considered opinion despite the the
embarrassment it causes them
of the u.s government of all of our
intelligence
all the relevant intelligence services
is that
this isn't a hoax it's too there's too
much data to suggest that it's a hoax
we've got too much radar imagery there's
too much
too much satellite data whatever data
whatever data they actually have
there's too much of it all we can say
now
is something's going on and
there's no way it's the chinese or the
russians or
anyone else's technology that should
that should arrest our attention you
know collectively
to to a degree that nothing in our
lifetime has and now
one worries that we're so
jaded and confused and distracted that
it's gonna it'll get much less coverage
than
than uh you know obama's tan suit did
you know a bunch of years ago it's just
it's uh who knows how we'll respond to
that but
uh it's just to say that
our the need for us to tell ourselves a
a an honest story about what's going on
and what's likely to happen next is
never going to go away
right and and it's important it's just
the the
division between me and every person
who's defending traditional religion is
where where is it that where is it that
you want to lie to yourself
or lie to your kids like where is
honesty a liability
and i and for me it you know i i've yet
to find the place where
it is and it's so obviously
a strength in almost every other
circumstance
because it is the thing that allows you
to course correct
it is the thing that allows you to
hope at least that your beliefs that
your stories
are in some kind of calibration with
what's actually
going on in the world yes it is a little
bit sad to imagine that
if aliens on mass showed up to earth
they would be too preoccupied with
political bickering
or to like these like fake news and all
that kind of stuff
to notice yeah the very basic uh
evidence of reality
i do have a glimmer of hope that
there seems to be more and more hunger
for authenticity
and i feel like that opens the door
for a hunger for what is
real like that people don't want story
they don't want like layers and layers
of
of uh like fakeness uh
and i'm hoping that means that will
directly lead to
a greater hunger for reality and reason
and truth
you know truth isn't dogmatism
like truth isn't uh authority i have a
phd
and therefore i'm right uh
truth is almost the like
the the reality is there's so many
questions there's so many mysteries
there's so much uncertainty this is our
best
available like a best guess and we have
a lot of evidence that supports that
guest
but it could be so many other things and
like just even conveying that
i think there's a hunger for that in the
world to hear that from scientists
less dogmatism and more just like
this is this is what we know we're doing
our best given the uncertainty given
i mean this is true with the obviously
with the virology and all those kinds of
things
because everything is happening so fast
there's a lot of
and biology is super messy so it's very
hard to know stuff for
sure so just being open and real about
that i think
i'm hoping will change people's
hunger and openness and trust of uh
what's real yeah well so much of this is
probabilistic it's
so much of what can seem dogmatic
scientifically it's just
you're just you're placing a bet on
whether it's worth reading that paper or
rethinking your presuppositions on that
point you know it's like it's not it's
not fundamental closure to data it's
just that
there's so much data on one side or so
or so much
so much would have to change in terms of
your understanding of
what you think you understand about the
nature of the world if this new fact
were so
that you can
pretty quickly say all right that's
probably [ __ ] right
like and it can sound like a fundamental
closure
to new conversations new evidence new
new data new argument but it's really
not it's just it really is just triaging
your attention
it's just like like okay you're telling
me that uh
your best friend can actually read minds
okay well
that's interesting let me know when that
person has gone into a lab and actually
proven it right like i don't need
like this this is not the place where i
need to spend the rest of my day
figuring out if your buddy can can read
my mind right
but there's a way to communicate that i
think i think it does too often sound
like you're completely closed off to
ideas
as opposed to saying like this is you
know
as opposed to saying that there's
there's a lot of evidence
in support of this but you're still
open-minded to other ideas like there's
a way to communicate that it's not
necessarily even with words
it's like it's even that joe rogan
energy of
it's entirely possible just it's that
energy of being open-minded and curious
like kids are
like this is our best understanding but
you still
are curious i'm not saying allocate
time to exploring all those things but
still leaving the door
open and there's a way to communicate
that i think that
that that that people really hunger uh
for let me ask you this i've been
recently talking a lot with john donahue
from brazil
brazilian jiu-jitsu fame i don't know if
you know what that is yeah
in fact i'm talking about somebody who's
good at what he does yeah
and he speaking of somebody who's
open-minded the reason
doing this ridiculous transition is for
the longest time and even still
a lot of people believed in the jiu
jitsu world and grappling world that
leglocks are not effective in jujitsu
and he was somebody
that uh inspired by the open mindedness
of dean lister
famously to him said why do you only
consider half the human body
when you're trying to do the submissions
he developed an entire system on this
other
half of the human body anyway i do that
absurd transition
uh to ask you because you're uh you're
also a student in brazilian jiu jitsu
is there something you could say how
that has affected your life what you've
learned
from grappling from the martial arts
well
it's actually a great transition because
i think
[Music]
one of the things that's so beautiful
about jiu jitsu is that it
it does what we wish we could do in
every other area
of life where we're talking about this
difference between
knowledge and ignorance right like like
there's there's no
room for [ __ ] right you don't get
any credit for [ __ ]
there's uh the difference but the
amazing thing about jiu jitsu is that
the the difference between knowing
what's going on and what to do and not
knowing it is as
the gulf between those two states is as
wide as it is in any
thing in in human life
and the it's spanned it can be spanned
so quickly like you you like you you
didn't each increment of knowledge can
be doled out in
five minutes it's like here's the thing
that got you killed
and here's how to here's how to prevent
it from happening to you and here's how
to do it
to others and you just get this this
this
amazing cadence of discovering your
fatal ignorance
and then having it remedied with the
actual
technique um and i mean just
for people who don't know what we're
talking about it's just like this the
simple
circumstance of like someone's got you
in a headlock how do you get out of that
right someone's sitting on your chest
and you know they're in the mount
position
and you're on the bottom and you want to
get away how do you get them off you
they're sitting on you
your intuitions about how to do this are
terrible
even if you've done some other martial
art right and
once you learn how to do it
the the difference is night and day it's
like you have access to a completely
different physics
but i think our
understanding of the world can be much
more like
jiu-jitsu than it tends to be right and
i think we should all
we should all have a much better sense
of
when we should tap out and when we
should recognize that our
our you know our epistemological arm
is barred and now being broken right now
the problem with
debating most other topics is that most
people
it isn't jujitsu and most people don't
tap out right they don't
even if they're wrong even if it's
obvious to you they're wrong and it's
obvious to the
intelligent audience that they're wrong
people just double down and double down
they're either lying or lying to
themselves or they're just they're
bluffing
and so you have a lot of zombies walking
around and zombie world views walking
around which
have been disconfirmed as emphatically
as
someone gets armbard right or someone
gets choked out in in jiu jitsu
but because it's not jiu-jitsu
they're they can they can they can live
to fight another day right or they can
pretend
that they didn't lose that particular
argument and
and science when it works is a lot like
jiu jitsu i mean science
when you falsify a thesis right when you
think
you know dna is one way and it proves to
be another way when you when you think
it's um
you know triple stranded or whatever
it's it's like there there is a there
there
and you can get to a real consensus
um so jiu jitsu for me it was like
it was more than just of interest for
self-defense and
and uh you know the the sport of it it
was just there was something
it's a language and an argument you're
having
where um
you can't fool yourself anymore like
this there's a
first of all it cancels any role of luck
in a way that most uh most other other
athletic feats don't it's like in
basketball you know you can even if
you're not good at basketball you can
take the basketball in your hand
you can you can be 75 feet away and
hurl it at the basket and you might make
it and you could convince yourself
based on that demonstration that you
have some kind of talent for basketball
right
enough you know 10 minutes on the mat
with a with a you know a real jiu-jitsu
practitioner when you're not one
proves to you that you just there is
it's not like there's no lucky punch
there's no you're not going to get a l
you're not there's no lucky rear naked
choke you're going to perform on someone
who beyond you know who's
you know marcelo garcia or somebody it's
just it it's not going to happen
and having that aspect of
of um
the usual range of uncertainty and
self-deception
and and [ __ ] just stripped away was
was really a kind of revelation it was
real it was just an amazing experience
yeah i think it's a really powerful
thing that accompanies whatever other
pursuit you have in life
i'm not sure if there's anything like
jiu jitsu
where you could just systematically go
go into a place
where you're that's honest
where your beliefs get challenged in a
way that's conclusive
yeah i haven't found too many other
mechanisms which is why
it's uh we had this earlier question
about fame and
ego and so on i'm very much
rely on jiu jitsu my own life as a place
where i can always go to
to have my ego in check and that
that has uh effects on how i
live every other aspect of my life
actually even just doing any kind of um
for me personally physical challenges
like even running doing something that's
way too hard
for me and like pushing through that's
somehow humbling
some people talk about nature being
humbling in that kind of sense
where you kind of
see something really powerful like the
ocean
like if you go surfing and you realize
there's something much more powerful
than you that's also honest
that there's no way to uh that you're
just
like the spec that kind of puts you in
the right
uh scale of where you are in this world
and you just does that better than
anything else
we should say it's only within its frame
is it
truly the the kind of the the final
right answer to all the problems it
solves because
if you just put jiu jitsu into an mma
frame or a real
like a total self-defense frame then
there's a lot
to a lot of unpleasant surprises to
discover
there right like somebody who thinks all
you need is jiu jitsu to
you know win the ufc it gets punched in
the face a lot
you know even from uh even on the ground
so it's um and then you bring weapons in
you know it's like when you
talk to jiu jitsu people about you know
knife defense and self-defense right
like that
that opens the door to certain kinds of
delusions but the analogy of martial
arts is is
fascinating because on the other side we
have
you know endless testimony now of fake
martial arts
that don't seem to know they're fake and
are as dilute i mean
they're impossibly delusional i mean
there's great video of joe rogan
watching some of these videos because
people send them to
them all the time but like literally
they're people they're people who
clearly believe in magic where the the
master isn't even touching the students
and they're they're flopping over so
this this
there's this kind of shared delusion
which you would think
maybe is just a performance and it's all
a kind of elaborate fraud but there are
cases where
the people and there's one you know
fairly famous case if you're a
connoisseur of this
of this madness where this older martial
artist who you saw flipping his
students endlessly by magic without
touching them
issued a challenge to the to the wide
world of martial artists
uh and someone showed up and just you
know punched him
in the face until it was over um clearly
he
believed his own publicity at some point
right and so that like
it is it's this amazing metaphor it
seems
again it should be impossible but if
that's possible
nothing we see under the guise of
religion or
or political bias or even you know
scientific
bias should be surprising to us i mean
it's so easy to see the work that that
you know cognitive bias is doing for
people when
when you can get someone who is ready to
issue a challenge to the world
you know who thinks he's got magic
powers yeah that's uh
human nature on clear display let me ask
you about love
mr sam harris you did an episode of
making sense with your wife
annika harris that was very entertaining
too um what does what role does love
play
in uh your life or in a life well lived
again asking from an engineering
perspective yeah yeah
i mean it is something that we we should
want to build
into our powerful machines
love at bottom is i mean love people can
mean many things by love
i think i think that what we should mean
by it most of the time
is a a deep commitment to the well-being
of those we love i mean your love your
love is synonymous with really wanting
the other person to be happy
and even wanting to and being made happy
by their happiness and being made happy
in the you know in their presence so
like
you're you're at bottom you're on the
same team
emotionally even when you're you might
be disagreeing more superficially about
something or trying to negotiate
something
it's just you're you
it can't be zero-sum in any important
sense
for love to actually be manifest in that
moment
see i have a different just a side
interrupt yeah go for it i have a
sense i don't know if you've ever seen
much of the penguins
my view of love is like there's it's
like a cold
wind it's blown like it's like this
terrible
suffering that's all around us right and
love is like the huddling of the two
penguins for warmth
right it's not necessarily that you're
like you're basically escaping
the cruelty of life by together for
time living in an illusion of some kind
of
the the magic of human connection that
social connection
that we have that kind of grows with
time
as we're surrounded by
basically the absurdity of life or
is the suffering of life that's why
they're in england
there is that too i mean there is the
warmth component right like
you're made happy by your connection
with the the person you love
yeah otherwise you you wouldn't it
wouldn't be
compelling right so it's not that you're
you have two different modes you want
them to be happy
and then you want to be happy yourself
and those are not those are just like
two separate games you're playing no
it's like you you're you found someone
who
uh you have a you have a positive
social feeling i mean again the
love love doesn't have to be as personal
as it tends to be for us i mean like
there's personal love there's
your actual spouse or your your family
or your friends
but potentially you could feel love for
strangers
insofar as that your wish that they're
that they not suffer and that their
hopes and dreams be realized becomes
palpable to you i mean like you can
actually feel
just tr reflects of joy at the joy of
others when you see someone's
face a total stranger's face light up in
happiness
that can become more and more contagious
to you and it can it can
it can become so contagious to you that
you really feel
permeated by it and it's just like so
that so it really is not zero sum when
you see someone else succeed
you know and and they're you know the
the light bulb of joy
goes off over their head you feel the
analogous joy
for them and and it's not just and
you're no longer keeping score you're no
longer feeling diminished by their
success it's just like that's
their success becomes your success
because you feel that same joy that they
because you actually want them to be
happy
right you you're not there's no miserly
attitude around happiness there's enough
to go around
um so i think love ultimately is that
and then our then
our personal cases are the people we're
devoting
all of this time and attention to in our
lives
it does have that sense of refuge from
the storm
you know it's like when someone gets
sick or when some bad thing happens
they're these are the people who you're
most in it together with you know when
once
or when some real condition of
uncertainty presents itself
but ultimately it can't even be about
successfully warding off
uh the grim punch line at the end of
life because we i mean we know we're
going to lose
everyone we love we know or they're
going to lose us first right so this
like it's not
it isn't in the end it's not even
an antidote for that problem it's just
it is just the
uh and we get we get to have this
amazing
experience of being here together
and and love is the is the
mode in which we really appear to make
the most of that right where it's not
just it no longer feels like a a
solitary infatuation
you know you're just you've got your
hobbies and your interests and your
your and you're captivated by all that
it's actually
there there are this is a domain
where somebody else's well-being
actually
can supersede your own your your your
concern for someone else's well-being
supersedes your own and so there's this
mode of self-sacrifice that doesn't even
feel like self-sacrifice because of
course
you care more about you know of course
you would take your child's pain if you
could right like that that's that's you
don't even have to
do the math on that and that's um
that just opens it this is the
kind of experience that just it it
pushes at the apparent boundaries of
self
in ways that reveal that there's just
there's just way more space in the mind
than than you were experiencing when it
was just all about you and what could
you what kind of what can i get
next and do you think we'll ever build
robots that we can love
and they will love us back well i think
we will
certainly seem to because we'll we'll
build those
you know i mean i think i think that
turing test will be passed
whether what will actually be going on
on the robot side uh may remain a
question
that that that will be interesting but i
think if we just
keep going we will build
very lovable you know irresistibly
lovable
robots that seem to love us yes i do i
do think and you don't find that
compelling that they will seem to love
us as opposed to actually love us
you think there is still nevertheless is
a i know we talked about consciousness
there being a distinction
but with love is there a distinction too
isn't love an illusion yeah you saw you
saw
ex machina right yeah i mean she
certainly seemed to love him until
she got out of the box isn't that what
all relationships are like
maybe you wait long enough
depends which box you're talking about
okay um no i mean like
that's that's the problem that's that's
where super intelligence you know
uh becomes a little scary when you
think of the prospect of being
manipulated by something that has
is intelligent enough to form a reason
and a plan to manipulate you you know
like a
and this there's no there's once we
build
robots that are truly out of the uncanny
valley
that you know look like people and
can express everything people can
express well then there's no re
then then then it that does seem to me
to be like
chess where once they're better they're
they're
so much better at deceiving
us than people would be i mean people
are already good enough at deceiving us
it's very hard to tell when somebody's
lying
but if you can imagine something that
could give facial
a facial display of any emotion it wants
at you know on cue uh
because if we've perfected the facial
display of emotion in robots in the year
you know 20 70 or whatever it is um
then it is just it is like chess against
the thing that isn't going to lose to a
human ever again in chess
it's not like kasparov is going to get
lucky next week
against the best against you know alpha
0 or whatever the best
algorithm is at the moment he's never
going to win again
i mean that that is that i believe
that's true in chess
and has been true for at least a few
years
it's not going to be like you know four
games to seven
it's gonna it's gonna be
human zero until the end of the world
right see i don't know i don't know if
love is like chess i think uh
the flaws no i'm talking about
manipulation manipulation
but i don't know if love and so
the kind of love we're referring to
if we have a if we have a robot that can
display credibly display
love and is
super intelligent and
we're not we're again we this stipulates
a few things but there are a few simple
things i mean we're out of the
uncanny valley right so it's like yes
you never have a moment where you're
looking at his face and you think oh
that didn't quite look right right this
is just
problem solved and
it's it will be like
doing arithmetic on your phone it's not
going to be you're not
left thinking is it really going to get
it this time if i
divide by seven i mean it's
it has solved arithmetic see i don't i
don't know about that because if you
look at chess
most humans no longer play
uh alpha zero they don't there's no
they're not part of the competition they
don't do it for fun except to study the
game of chess
you know the highest level chess players
do that we're still human on human
so in order for ai to get integrated to
where
you would rather play chess against an
ai system well
you would rather that no no i'm not
saying i i don't know
manipulation on that i'm just saying
what is it going to be like to be in
relationship to something
that can seem to be feeling
anything that a human can seem to feel
and it can do that impeccably
right and has end is smarter than you
are right that's
that's a circumstance of you know
insofar as it's possible to be
manipulated that is the that is the the
asymptote
of of that possibility let me ask you
the last question
without any serving it up without any
explanation
what is the meaning of life
i think it is either the wrong question
or that question is answered
by
paying sufficient attention to any
present moment
such that there's no there's no
basis upon which to to pose that
question it's not answered in the usual
way it's not it's not a matter of having
more information
it's it's having more engagement
with reality as it is in the present
moment or consciousness as it is in the
present moment
you don't ask that question when you're
most captivated by the most important
thing you ever pay attention to it
that's a that's a question only gets
asked
when you're abstracted away from that
experience that peak experience
and you're left wondering why are
so many of my other experiences mediocre
right like why am i repeating the same
pleasures every day why do
why is my netflix queue just like
when's this going to run out like i've
seen so many shows like this am i really
going to watch another one like
you're all of that that's a moment where
you're
not actually having the beatific vision
right you're not you're you're not sunk
into the present moment and
you're not truly in love like you're in
a relationship with somebody who you
know
you know conceptually you love right
this is the person you're
living your life with but you don't
actually feel good together
right like if you if you so like it's
it's in
in those moments of where attention
hasn't found a good enough reason to
truly sink
into the present so as to obviate any
any concern like that right and
that's what that's why meditation is
this kind of superpower because
until you learn to meditate you think
you're like the outside world or the
circumstances of your life
always have to get arranged so that
the present moment can become good
enough to to demand your attention
in a in a a way that makes that seems
fulfilling that that makes you happy
and so if you're if it's jiu-jitsu you
think okay i gotta get back on the mat
it's been
it's been months since i've trained you
know it's been over a year since i've
trained it's coveted
when am i going to be able to to train
again that's the only place i feel
great right or you know i've got a ton
of work to do
i'm not going to be able to feel good
until i get all this work done right so
i've got some
deadline that's coming you always think
that your life has to change the world
has to change
so that you can finally have a good
enough excuse
to truly to to just be
here and hear is enough you know that
where the present moment becomes
totally captivating meditation is the
only
i mean meditation is another name for
the discovery
that you can actually just train
yourself to do that on demand
so that like i mean just looking at a
cup can be good enough
in precisely that way and any
sense that it might not be
is recognized to be a thought that
is mysteriously unravels the moment you
notice it and then and you fall
and that the moment expands and becomes
more diaphanous
and then there's no then there's no
evidence
that this isn't the best moment of your
life right like this it doesn't and
again it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be pulling all the
reins and levers of pleasure it's not
like
oh my this tastes like chocolate you
know this is the most chocolatey moment
of my life no it's just
the the sense data don't have to change
but
the sense that there is some kind of
basis for doubt about the rightness of
being
in the world in this moment that can
evaporate
when you pay attention and
that is the meaning of the kind of the
meta answer to that question
the meaning of life for me is to
live in that mode more and more and to
whenever i notice i'm not in that mode
to
recognize it and return and and to not
be
to to to cease
more and more to take the reasons why
reasons why not uh at face value because
we all have
reasons why we can't be fulfilled in
this moment
it's like this i've got all these
outstanding things that i'm worried
about
right it's like it's you know there's
there's that
thing that's happening later today that
i you know i'm anxious about whatever it
is
we're constantly deferring our sense of
this is this is it you know this is not
a dress rehearsal this is the show
we keep deferring it and we just have
these moments on the calendar where we
think okay this is this is where it's
all going to land it's that vacation i
planned with my five best friends you
know we do this once every three years
and now we're going
and here we are on the beach together
unless you have a mind that can really
pay attention
really cut through the chatter really
sink into the present moment
you can't even enjoy those moments the
way they should be enjoyed the way you
dreamed you would enjoy them
when they arrive so it's i mean so it's
a meditation in the sense it's the great
equalizer it's like
it's you don't have to you don't have to
live with the illusion anymore
that you need a good enough reason and
things are going to get better when you
do have those good reasons it's like
there's just a mirage-like quality to
every future attainment
and every future breakthrough and every
future peak experience
that eventually you get the lesson that
you never quite arrive right like you
you won't you don't you don't
arrive until you cease to step over the
present moment in search of
the next thing i mean we're constantly
we're stepping over the thing that we
think we're
seeking in the act of seeking it and so
it is kind of a paradox
i mean there is a there's this paradox
that
which i mean it sounds trite but it's
like you you can't
actually become happy
you can only be happy and and and it's
that it's the illusion that because
it's the loot it's the illusion that
your future being happy
can be predicated on this act of
becoming
in any domain you know and becoming
includes this sort of
you know further under further
scientific understanding on the
questions that interest you
or you know um getting
in better shape or whatever the thing is
whatever the whatever the contingency of
your
dissatisfaction seems to be in any
present moment
real attention solves the koan
you know in in a way that
becomes a very different place from
which to then make
any further change it's not that you
just have to dissolve into a puddle of
goo i mean you can still get in shape
and you can still do all the things that
you know the superficial things that
are obviously good to do but the sense
that
your well-being is over there is um
really does diminish and eventually
just becomes a it becomes a kind of
non-sequitur
so well there's a sense in which
in this conversation actually
experienced many of those things
the sense that i've arrived so i
mentioned to you offline
it's very true that i start i've been a
fan of yours for many years
and the reason i started this podcast
speaking of ai systems is to manipulate
you sam harrison to doing this
conversation
so like on the calendar literally you
know i've always had the sense people
ask me
when are you going to talk to sam harris
and i always answered eventually
right because i always felt again tying
our free will thing that somehow that's
going to happen
i and it's one of those manifestation
things or something i don't know if it's
maybe i am a robot i'm just not
cognizant of it and i manipulated you
into having this conversation so it was
a
i mean i don't know what the purpose of
my life past this point is
so if i've arrived so in that sense i
mean all that to say
uh i'm only partially joking on that uh
is
it really uh is a huge honor that you
would waste this time with me yeah
well it really means a lot listen it's
mutual i'm a big fan of yours and as you
know i reached out to you for this
so so this is uh um it's great i love
what you're doing
you're doing something more and more
indispensable
in this world on on your podcast and
you're doing it differently than
than rogan's doing it or that i'm doing
it i mean
you have you definitely found your own
lane and it's it's wonderful
thanks for listening to this
conversation with sam harris and thank
you to
national instruments valcampo athletic
greens
and linode check them out in the
description
to support this podcast and now let me
leave you with some words from sam
harris
in his book free will you are not
controlling the storm
and you are not lost in it you are the
storm
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time